you found yourself at the junction where
worlds meet politics civility how about
honesty in this country folks
entertainment and a whole bunch of other
stuff about having a healthy body image
give a very unhealthy body you should
have a horrible body it's not a big
moment through the market maturity we
are definitely going to get letters
you're listening to talk radio strangest
animal
[Music]
you're getting louder with Crowder
oh yes the third show in June which
marks louder with Crowder's official
cultural appropriation join us each week
as we travel the globe appreciate and
illuminating you on all the great
cultures this world has to offer up this
week the ancient culture of the Middle
East
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
glad to be with you that sound is a
sound of the weekend don't weaken don't
speak when your burka do you don't speak
to me I am your host steven crowder of
course producing with me in studio as
always is not gauge aired you can follow
him on twitter at not gay jared he is
not gay I fulfilled my legal obligations
draw your own conclusions we good
we're fine you can speak ever good I'll
give you information or good you are
good you know we're doing cultural
appropriation month of course that
continues this week waited Mexico China
now the Middle East reason we depict the
Middle East is just because there's no
particular standout country so we went
with a region which i think is more fair
you know you don't have to wear that
burke of the whole night this the burka
you have to wear the whole night you can
take it off I'm actually I have to get
rid of the beard here because this is
not gonna make it possible for me to
talk so
alright glad to be with you we have some
tremendous guests here tonight we have
Dave Rubin who will come on the show
later we'll have a discussion about gun
control we'll have discussion a debate
about the gun control so you look good
your face looks good you have to hide
that pretty face behind a burqa you're
here in North America I appreciate it
just the way God made you and then we
are going to have Gerald Morgan of
course in the secondary guests great
guest who really doesn't know a whole
lot about Islam we'll be talking about
Islam and we will have any cyrus on at
the the half-hour here who was a child
bride in Islam and knows it pretty well
knows the religion pretty well let me
move my seat here because it's my garb I
don't know how they live like this no
wonder they drowned in record numbers
and they're in the beds a real
properties you know that with the burqa
it's a real problem all right a little
bit of a new setup and some big
announcements to make I don't know why
not gay Jarrett is laughing so hard so
we're glad to be with you this week of
course a horrible tragedy this week all
right let's start this off you know it's
it's mandatory to say thoughts and
what's that I'm not sure what that is
but it I like the jam oh is that mean
it's a it's call to prayer it must be
getting close it's called the prayer
time which directions Mecca he was that
one over there okay
we got it take part in your prayer Jared
there you go we got okay we faced mechon
we did a prayer so listen we it's a
terrible week mandatory to say thoughts
and prayers and of course that's true
and I hate the fact that we have to
politicize these issues right away I
hate the fact that that happens but it's
reality and conservatives need to accept
anyone who's anti-authoritarian needs to
accept that it is reality this happened
of course the tragic shooting in Orlando
and before the bodies were even cold
when a man named Omar Mateen opened fire
on a bunch of gays in a nightclub
because they were gay and because he was
Muslim and pledged his allegiance to
Isis we are talking about gun control
that is what's happened right off the
bat and we've gotten so far left in this
country let me give you a couple of I'll
give you a couple of important pieces
and let me go general for you and then
we'll come back we'll talk specific news
of the day Sally Kohn got really mad at
me will bring up we'll talk about those
tweets later well rebut Samantha bee
later and Conan O'Brien we don't want to
do it right now right off the bat let's
give you the general idea first the
Marley's were dead to begin with this
man went to the security checks he
wasn't on a terror list he wasn't on a
no-fly list and he didn't use an ar-15
wasn't on a terror list wasn't on a
no-fly list didn't go through a loophole
and he didn't use an ar-15
that's important for people to know
because people wanna repeat in your been
ar-15 ar-15 ar-15 a ar-15 they want to
make you scared of that rifle even
though they've never fired it they have
no idea what a semi-automatic weapon is
they have no idea what an assault rifle
is because it doesn't exist but they
want to drill this in your head
repetition repetition repetition
repetition of the lie none of those
things are true okay
I've written about a lot of those credit
calm start with that Sally Kohn gets up
and right away the left is saying
Christians including the ACLU Christian
conservatives created this environment
because we don't want penises in the
ladies room Sally Kohn talked about
Christians and their their anti-gay
bigotry because because of private
bakery not wanting to bake a gay wedding
cake and slaughtering 50 gays we met 49
gays in a nightclub that the
comparability is striking it's more or
less the same thing it's why it's in the
ballpark and the Sally cone brand
so I tweeted her on Twitter saying yeah
Baker's not baking a cake versus 50
homos dead in a nightclub that I can see
the similarity now it's Twitter she gets
off on the homos how dare you use the
word people are more offended about an
abbreviation of the medically correct
term homosexual then they are the fact
that Islam is killing record numbers of
gays across the globe and it's happening
on your own soil the left is more
offended if you say the wrong word I
don't know if queer is the right word or
if it's gay half the time there's LGBTQ
some people tell you queer is the Q is
queer some people tell you that it's
questioning they're more concerned with
the words why why are they more
concerned with the words when 50 people
are dead I'll tell you why they're more
concerned with the words because they
know they can hang you on them they know
that they can hang you on the words if
people are focusing on the words if
people are focusing on the joke they
don't actually examine the policy they
don't actually examine the heart behind
the words they don't actually have to
face evil in the face that's why people
like Sally Cohen are doing it that's why
they want to make it about the ar-15
they don't want to acknowledge that we
have evil amongst us and here's the
thing conservatives we need to be honest
about this okay good guy with a gun
would be know that may not be true do I
think good guys with guns are but yes do
I believe you should go buy a firearm as
a matter of fact I think that everybody
out there right now should not only buy
a firearm I want to see trending hashtag
gift a gun if you have any loved ones or
friends who are responsible
obviously in clear medical health who
don't own a firearm you should purchase
them a firearm as a gift why because
when it's shipped to them to their local
FFL dealer they will have to go through
the paperwork now even though they don't
fire that gun even if they don't like it
they have to go pick it up because you
filed it under your name and you've
shipped it to them right they have to go
pick it up they will have to fill out
paperwork in a background check here's
why that's important the easiest way to
refute the propaganda that's coming out
from Barack Obama and Hillary Clinton
where they say you can get it you can
get a machine gun without a background
check all it takes is for someone to
have ever purchased a firearm what if
they've done it once they can say sorry
Jarrod [ __ ] for Terrestrial gonna
have that dump button bull [ __ ]
anyone who's ever purchased a firearm
knows it is absolute complete patent
[ __ ] they've done it illegally I
don't know I'm not talking of the Bloods
of the Crips that's why so here's the
beauty of this the second amendment
fundamental gun rights are a winning
issue because over 90 million Americans
have guns at least hundreds of millions
of guns in the United States of America
and you want to make that more because
every single one of them knows that it's
a lie that you can get a gun without a
background check or did a background
check would step a crazy person who
getting a gun by the way the no-fly list
it's a joke and anyone who wants to use
it as a litmus test for your fundamental
human rights is a joke
whether it's Hillary Clinton or Donald
Trump we don't know who it is yet Donald
Trump said he wanted to talk with the
NRA about not letting no-fly lists errs
get guns he could mean that he wants to
say we shouldn't not to let them get
guns he could do the double negative I
don't know but that's a deal breaker for
me Boston Globe or boss was a Boston
Globe Boston press it's one of those
Boston Boston gloves vast and Boston
Globe wants to they want to release
permit information publicly that's
setting a crime map here's something the
second amendment we'll get into this
we'll get to the rebuttal of Samantha
bee and Conan O'Brien the Second
Amendment when taken very literally it's
beautiful it's like the Constitution
sorry it's not like it's like the Quran
the Constitution or or the the Bible the
second I meant when taken literally is
really clear the right of the people not
the right of the militia the right of
the people shall not be infringed period
very clear when taken contextually the
Second Amendment is even more clear to
me for most kids which is so funny they
go ar-fifteens are a weapon of war and
have no place in it well what do you
think the weapons of war were back then
dummy muskets and tanks not tanks
cannons so they didn't have tanks
cannons muskets and cannons they were
too light tanks I would have loved tanks
cannons and guess what Founding Fathers
said yes to cannon there was a letter of
marque and reprisal we've talked about
that I think was Jefferson was it
Madison or a letter of marque another
easel Madison private ship and it wasn't
written like okay we'll give you
permission to have cannons it was what
of course you can have cannons that's
why we wrote the right to bear arms and
not muskets no free man shall
ever have his arms stripped these are
direct quotes when you read more letters
when you look at the historical context
it only becomes more strong that's the
beauty of the Second Amendment
that's why Michael Woods Jr who was on
Joe Rogan talking about how we need to
rewrite the Second Amendment agreed to
come on the show we'll talk about him
later
I've looked into his past agreed to come
on the show then change the term said he
would only come on if people gave to a
GoFundMe then said he wouldn't come on
because the left can't defend it it's
their biggest losing issue so the Second
Amendment is really clear I invite
anybody out there anybody out there who
can give me a convincing argument that
the Second Amendment was mint meant only
for muskets during that period of time
anyone that it wouldn't apply to modern
firearms and that same breath you'd have
to make the argument that the First
Amendment doesn't apply to people
tweeting from their pipe phone so that
but then the question comes up and not
gay Jared asked me this this week is the
second event is the juice worth two
squeeze are we at a point where the
negative ramifications are so great that
maybe we need to do with away with it
that's what people are saying no that's
another argument from the left just do
away with the Second Amendment it's not
worth it anymore the cost of freedom is
too great good guy with a gun may not
stop all of them we need to acknowledge
that you can't contain evil are you
doing this are we doing this again
yeah I got a break soon we're going to
break soon yep Ready's yeah I wasn't
even finished with my rant time flies
when you're having a blast I thought we
were doing another call to prayer I wish
where's Mecca I don't know where Mecca
is we're going to break that way well
okay well we'll see we have to go pray
to Mecca
[Music]
well I didn't you just kill me it unfair
death your punishment must be more
severe
[ __ ] vote up newspaper more torture but
none of your body of your cheese's watch
me tear this country apart and I will do
it what I hope for poisoning ourselves
hope for sardines hope for cheese's I
know but I only think what's wrong with
the hope that sardines or cheese's
there's our empty promises and once the
country is ruined itself with all their
clones are mine big squirrel will
fulfill its destiny and then have my
permission to die
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
that is so creepy where am i in
Hamtramck Michigan I would like to see
the music got better at some point that
got picked up but you know someone ran
some time and it was a top 40 hit well
everything is tough that's top 40
everything there every top 40 in that
country the suitors want to hear the
next song on that list it's the same
song and then some Muslims don't like
music that's sure that's the thing -
okay couple of things I've got this up
on my screen
from The Wall Street Journal there were
suspicions of the orlando shooter and
actually some some firearm store's
dealers refused to sell a memo and you
see left us praising this well it's
great well yeah shouldn't private
businesses have the right to refuse any
service then do that I don't want to
cater your wedding why is it cuz I'm gay
I don't like your face I don't like your
bowl-cut leave I would like to purchase
a thousand rounds of ammo okay and your
name Omar no bhai if you want to get
real about the lists you need to get
real that profiling here there's one
problem the problem is Islam but I'm
surprised that leftists aren't aren't
talking about how hey it's great that
private businesses have the right to
make some judgment calls sometimes
sometimes get it wrong but they should
have the right to make safety calls
whether it's a gun or it's a cake when
it comes to the Second Amendment I was
talking about this before the break some
people are saying is the juice worth the
squeeze is it are the effects worse is
this the cost of freedom we'll talk
about that later with Samantha be okay
the cost of freedom sometimes good guys
with the guns won't won't stop but you
have to accept that you cannot contain
evil and sometimes this is a cost of
freedom that'll be a soundbite someone
says the mass shooting should continue
because it's the cost of freedom listen
violence is down okay after the assault
weapons ban you remove Chicago Baltimore
gang violence the mass shootings have
not gone up okay statistically it's not
this this bloodbath out there that
people want now this is a horrific
incident no one is belittling instant
the incident no one is marginalizing the
incident but you can't control evil me
evil is Islam the evil is not the ar-15
which wasn't used is the juice worse
worth the squeeze the second one well
let me tell you what is the Second
Amendment given you okay
the Second Amendment is the United
States is important to note it is
founded on violence the United States
was created very specifically
justifiable homicide justifiable
homicide against redcoats coming from a
monarchy and an evil oppressive corrupt
government who never allowed their
people to have guns so the Second
Amendment in a modern society do you get
some shootings yeah but guess what
without the Second Amendment you would
never have this modern society it
wouldn't exist the Industrial Revolution
the technological leaps and bounds
electricity lightbulbs all of them have
come to you courtesy of the United
States why because of freedom freedom to
innovate freedom to create no place left
the world's greatest most oppressive
superpower one century only to become
the world's only superpower the next
century it's never happened before or
since not to this level you know what
happened you know how they did that with
firearms with the Second Amendment they
said we're not going to do it like them
the only way we can make this work is by
being different and ensuring that all of
our Siddons citizens unlike those
jackasses over there in the Kings land
can protect themselves guess what else
the Second Amendment did stop free the
slaves the bloodiest war in American
history right Civil War never would've
happened without the Second Amendment
maybe some black Americans should be
pretty grateful to the Second Amendment
happen who do you think some farmers
with pitchforks are going yep you're
gonna do some of the gun yep yeah I do
so with that the founding of the United
States which could have never taken
place without the Second Amendment which
was very clearly again it clearly
expressed that everybody has the right
to bear arms again even contextually
it's more clear cannons high-capacity
firearms which existed back then of
course we've dispelled those myths
though many many times that's the only
way the United States could have ever
come to be and because of the United
States you have freedom of speech
because of the United States you have a
modern Free Press because of the United
States you don't have slavery here in
the United States slavery has been ended
mostly throughout the modern world it
still exists in the Islamic world again
let's go back to that killing gays they
still have slaves in a lot of those
countries and of course in third world
countries because of the United States
which could only come to be through the
Second Amendment you have the Industrial
Revolution you have the technological
revolution you're able to watch this
freely on your computer or on your iPad
none of those things could have happened
without freedom and freedom could not
have happened for the entire world
without the United States
without the Second Amendment it was
pivotal that's why it was in there is
number two so you want to talk about
culture that culture created everything
that you were using and enjoying right
now and by the way there are plenty of
other violent Combe right to the south
of us we have Mexico that's the cost of
freedom what's the cost of not freedom
the cost of not freedom is a record rape
in Sweden the cost of not freedom the
cost of authoritarianism of course you
have historical examples like Stalin
Hitler Mao Pol Pot but let's just talk
today the cost of not freedom is a
groping and getting your hooch grabbed
by someone free of charge at a German
music festival the cost of no freedom is
being put in jail for saying something
unpopular or even playing God forbid
kung fu fighting which is labeled as
hate speech the cost of not freedom is
going to prison for two years for using
the word [ __ ] as could happen in
Canada that's the cost of not freedom oh
and by the way they still have mass
killings yeah sometimes the cost of
freedom is not pretty but conservatives
need to also stop lying and say well we
can stop this with more guns no no do I
think it will be better yes because an
armed society is a polite society but
you can't fix it I'm not bringing
tidings of great joy here there is a
cost to freedom and if you look at it
throughout history it's been bloody but
everyone benefits and so I'm a little
tired of these other places with
crappier inferior cultures a lot of
these cultural if you want to talk about
Mexico or if you want to talk about some
places in Europe you want to talk about
places in the Middle East these people
who are piping in talking about how we
need to implement gun control other
cultures outside of Western European or
American cultures we used to have a word
for them it was an umbrella term
savagery that was the term we used for
other cultures because ours is better
than theirs you can send your letters to
me or tweet me at s Crowder I'm a little
tired of them telling us how we should
run our culture well Mexico has a
violent culture but plenty of countries
with violent cultures liberals aren't
trying to get me they're praising
Venezuela and Chavez for crying out loud
so just accept that actually the United
States does not have greater violence
than the UK certainly not stabbings or
muggings not overall violent crime rate
but yeah guns are used in some more
crimes and it's a more effective tool
except that maybe that's a part of our
culture which isn't inherently more
violent than everyone else's but it's a
culture that allowed you to even benefit
from your culture it's the culture that
allows you to even exist at this point
yeah I think the Second Amendment
and the gun culture freedom is worth the
price I hope I've crystallized my answer
for you gift a gun
hashtag gift a gun because anyone out
there who purchases a firearm
knows that what is being peddled right
now is a lie so okay we're going to get
back with Gerald in the second hour
talking about Islam more theologically
Annie Cyrus is coming up next
she was personally a child bride
personally married off lived in Iran and
fled it and so we're going to talk about
her story personally first then come
into the macro we've moved past guns
because you're logical people were going
to go to the evil that is Islam the
greatest evil of our time worse than
Nazism they hate Jews just as much hate
them they hate a stain them they hate
them absolutely just as much louder with
Crowder stay tuned Annie Cyrus next I
can't believe he said that oh there you
are you caught me on my off time you
know you're probably watching this video
cast on YouTube or Facebook or maybe
you'd caught the live video stream
Thursday nights 8 p.m. Eastern 7 o'clock
central I don't know but many of you
don't know you can subscribe on iTunes
or SoundCloud the audio version has
exclusive commercial sketches and you
can take it with you on the go plus it's
free and I know many of you are cheap
bastards so
always looking out for you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
glad to come back glad to come back with
this next guest with that fabulous bump
from Pogue fabulous if you haven't heard
of you can go downloaded stuff Pogo is
the name Australian artist brilliant and
this next lady is brilliant you can find
out all of her aloha all of her work at
live up to freedom calm fascinating life
story migrated to the United States fled
Islamic oppression and I'm not going to
get a first name correct so we'll go
with the Twitter handle kind of like
Asian nail salons where all of a sudden
their name is Tammy yes well go with
Annie Cyrus thank you so much for being
with us thank you for having me well
don't think it'll be your pleasure we
haven't gotten into it yet and usually
people change their opinion so we got an
email from from Tony bugle friend of the
show said you have to have her on and
I've actually seen your stuff around you
really specialize not only in Sharia law
and how it treats women and of course
your excoriated for some of the stuff
that you talk about but what's really
important is you've had first-hand
experience for those who don't know you
were from what I when you were you were
sold off as a child bride very young and
well you take it so I don't botch it why
have you made this your life's mission
to educate people on Islam that's
relation with women well I was born and
raised in Islamic Republic of Iran with
an N again not a cute Iran and I
basically not only was an Islamic
country it was also a very Islamic
family that I grew up and my father was
a sheikh or better known as Imam here
and my mom was a Koran teacher and a
woman who would teach other woman how to
be a obeying good Muslim wife so I had
to face that inside and outside some
somehow some of the people get lucky in
inside their family they're not too
religious but in my case I had to deal
with both and growing up until age 15 I
basically face almost anything except
death a woman can face in Sharia law I
was put in prison I was lashed I was
sold to her marriage and I was beat up
obviously that's a very normal thing
that happens to a woman why like what
why did they just do it because it was
Thursday or because you you know you
were lippy what was their justification
well I do and did have a big mouth I
wasn't the type to just take it so I
would ask too many questions always
suspended from the school for asking too
many questions about Quran my dad a
couple of times punched me for asking
why do I have to cover my hair at age
seven going to school and the boys don't
do it or I would ask why do I have to do
the pray or I would ask you know I would
just keep asking questions and none of
them ever make sense to me until today
it doesn't make sense to me it won't it
there is no making sense out of Islam
because there is no sense it's just one
thing and one thing is you either obey
you end up dead that's just a way to now
some people say oh this is anecdotal it
was your personal experience it's not
necessarily representative of mainstream
in places like Iran or more moderate
places let's say you know like the UAE
that's what they'll say to try and rebut
this very interview what do you say to
those people
well I normally say gråvik Quran if you
don't have the actual whole copy go to
Quran Qur aan calm find forth surah
named and sign Arabic or the woman in
English 176 verses go ahead and read the
first 13 verses and you get your answer
on the first 13 verses it will tell you
Allah Himself that a woman is worth half
a person it will tell you to beat your
woman if she's not obeying you until she
obeys so keep beating until she comes
back to obeying you it does tell you
that if you feel like you need more than
one for one wife you are allowed to get
up to four permanent wives and unlimited
sex slaves well there you have it it's
right in your Quran well I would say
that that is an answer but they would
say that's not a
is that a fire alarm beeping that I'm
hearing off in your thing do you have
one of those is it a battery that's not
replaced oh you can't hear dad
I can hear y-you know it's just saying
it's because you're smoking you took off
the headdress and you're a good-looking
lady and it's saying this is what
happens when you're in Western society
I'm sorry wildly inappropriate I'm very
very beat me and I won't beat you
because I believe you catch more bees
with honey not beating the crap out of
them like black beard and Muslims do so
Mohammed did that now let me ask you
this point-blank and then we'll move on
with your story so just give me yes or
no did Mohammed have a child bride yes
didn't Mohammed beat his wife yes Danna
Hamid have sex with someone who was not
his wife as a sex slave yes okay that's
I want to make sure that's clear and
because you can go to live up to freedom
calm and Annie Cyrus will will explain
it far better than I haven't explained
it on the show I just want to make sure
that people know point-blank all those
things are true they can search them so
you're sold how old were you when you
were sold into being a bride I was about
13 14 when I was sold okay
now forgive me you don't have to answer
this they argue Mohammed didn't
consummate until several years after was
that pretty much this husband was able
to do whatever he wanted immediately oh
my my consummated the marriage at age
nine Aisha was six when he got her
but custom Asian was at age nine I was
13 14 way past that age yes so and and
was was that incredibly scary or was it
just kind of something that you knew so
you grew up with and so it was just sort
of another another day in the life for
me it wasn't so much as scary it pissed
me off because I hated the PA and I
couldn't say no I mean I tried saying no
pretty much every bone in my body has
been broken at least once I'm still
dealing with some broken bones believe
it or not I have to do two surgeries
because of bones he broke but it wasn't
so much of a scary now it pissed me off
right pretty much did it hate it it it
no I'm sure that no snake that made you
really mad but does it make you even
more mad that when you come out and you
speak about this because I've seen the
reactions to you
that privileged leftists in the United
States and California say well she's
just angry and bitter it's not
representative of Islam I would imagine
that is probably more overall upsetting
oh yes it does really piss me off and
they say oh you just had couple bad
experiences oh really right I'm giving
you verses from Quran and I'm giving you
a hadith from Muhammad and you're
telling me these are bad experiences yes
it does piss me off however I try to
control my anger Mike well that's true
one and now you um is this is this
effectively your life's work educating
people and lecturing yes pretty much
that's all I do 24/7 and do you do a lot
on college campuses what's the reaction
to that like right now because I've been
people have requested me be banned for
making jokes about Islam or of course
you know fat shaming whatever they're
triggered by today but since that's your
thing have you had any specific
reactions or been banned from from
campuses I was I was turned out turned
down by any college any high school any
university I ever send a request to have
a speech so where am i what are you do
you're speaking well pretty much all of
it is through my videos I do the videos
they get shared on social media and
YouTube sometimes they take him down and
if you have a backup so you put it back
on we I haven't had a single chance to
get anywhere as far as public speaking
yeah just won't let me well you know
what's funny - I think not only because
people don't like what you have to say
but even if people might agree with you
and I've seen this behind the scenes
they're too afraid to take the risk with
someone like you because it's it's a
real security factor sure they are
afraid so okay so what if you have to so
let's say I assume this is a video what
is it that you want people having lived
your life to understand about Islam
what's most important for them to get
that you think people are missing as
long as not a religion okay as long as
an ideology yes that's a main thing they
need to know because as soon as we get
that out of the way the very first thing
is they cannot hide behind our First
Amendment anymore so they can have a
freebie Pat's
okay so you say can't hand behind the
First Amendment's obviously we're
talking about no abridgement thereof as
relation to religion I was the press has
included freedom of speech what do you
mean they can't hide behind the First
Amendment would you shut down mosques do
you mean no with Sharia how far would
you go well to be honest if it's up to
me I would definitely go we had been
Sharia when you ban Sharia they can't
have must either because one thing about
mosque is a lot of people actually
automatically assume a mosque is where
they do their prayers and no they don't
as soon as a mosque goes up that means
that area has been conquered by Sharia
law that must turns into a Sharia court
meaning any person who's practicing
Islam any woman will be in danger in
that area because the husband doesn't
have to take actual legal steps anymore
they just go to their mom at the mosque
and take whatever order they want
including beheading and a stoning are
you saying all mosques all mosques the
function of Sharia Court yes the mosque
is also sure your court okay I didn't
know that because I know there's like 80
something mosques in Sharia Courts sorry
if officially in UK we have plenty of
mosques here in the United States those
are labeled as Sharia Courts are you
saying people are wrong that's under the
radar they're acting as courts yes
pretty much that's what it is if you
grab the al bukhari hadees book there
are over 72 hadith in there where
muhammad mentions that every imam that
runs a mosque has the power to make
decisions for family courts which terms
you're sure you're okay I guess I was
under the inter because I've listened
I'm very very hard on Islam if anyone
has seen the videos that have done I was
under the impression that maybe that
dealt more like with private marital
counseling or family disputes like you
might see in a Christian Church right a
couples having trouble they go in they
see a counselor and they try and remedy
the relationship or do you mean that or
you mean it goes further as to actually
making legal decisions like divorce with
legal ramifications yes
that's what a mom in a mosque does every
let's go back to Islamic Republic of
Iran for a second all of the judges are
actual Imams in order to become
judge you don't go in a study law you
study Sharia in order to be a judge
so all judges are Imams but does that
mean that all Imams are judges no it
depends on what level of Imam they are
however any Imam who runs a mosque is a
George okay in order to lead a mosque
you have to be a judge level of a mom
okay so you are allowed to send out FET
buzz okay explain what that is for
people who don't know myself in fact
what they pronounce in both ways oh I
know fatwa I know that so okay but
control the correct Arabic pronunciation
over this fatwa okay yeah that's hard
they say but it's basically a sentencing
that is given to a Muslim who has
disobeyed or walked away from Islam or
you know insulted a law or Mohammed or
anything that goes against Sharia law
that's the sentencing or judgment for
that Muslim it's called fatwa Wow
because the people have said they put a
fatwa on me can't can't it be done for a
non-muslim from for mocking Mohammed
because that's what I was told that I
had one on me for repeatedly mocking
Mohammed well you need to keep one thing
in mind in eyes of Muslims every person
that was ever born is Maha Marian or a
Muslim so you might think you're not a
Muslim but they look at you as a Muslim
who walked away from ideon and that's a
whole goal of Islam to turn the planet
back to its origin which is Mohammed II
well that's interesting because of
course people would say well Sharia law
or these you know they don't affect
anybody outside of the Islamic Circle
they have their own sort of think of it
as traditions but like you're saying
they see anyone who is not Muslim as
actually Muslim but needs to be punished
for refusing subjugation yes what is the
word they use apostate yes apostate yes
you see a lot of people say oh they're
in photo or proud in photo or cover we
at the end of the day - I have an actual
Muslim by meaning real Muslim not some
people who call themselves Muslims but
real Muslims we all are apostates
because we were
born a Muslim but we chose to have it
different faiths so we turned our back
just not right and of course that is
punishable by death I had a friend even
from her mother from Egypt had to flee
listen Annie sorry I'm going with Annie
I know it's something right now we're
gonna have to go to a break and I want
to bring you back live up to freedom
calm this is fascinating and she's she's
quite easy on the eyes to look and thank
God she made it to Western culture Lata
with Crowder stay tuned we'll be back
more with any Cyrus
[Music]
and now for actual studio conversation
[Music]
I know I've joked about it but what do
you think do you think Hillary Clinton
is straight do you think she's I don't
know she's a lesbian people talk about
it at I am but you don't what are you
like if you I'm not saying it's
definitive either way but do you think I
go back okay you know hero scenario gun
to your head your family said this is
escalated quickly yes no I'm serious
right now cuz just you have to give a
definitive answer so the family is at
gunpoint you have to bet your life and
your family's lives has to be one or the
other those are the stakes you have to
bet here and give an answer is his
lesbian
[Music]
this has been actual studio
conversations what a party we will party
hard
[Music]
glad to be back live up to freedom
dot-com our guest with us has taken the
time educating illuminating a nice iris
you can follow her on Twitter thank you
so much for being with us and I
appreciate your candor I can imagine
that this is tough to speak about for a
lot of people do you just plow through
it with anger no I do it because I know
I'm taking my revenge okay so there you
go it's like like a Jodie Foster film or
she buys a gun and she lurks the New
York subways I dig it I wouldn't want to
cross you hopefully you've been happy
with this interview because I get the
feeling that I have like a horse head in
my bed if you were mad well thank you I
am so you moved too you moved too while
you're in the United States now and it
seems like it's really hard you know
you're sounding an alarm and people
aren't listening do you feel like the
tide is maybe changing a little bit that
people are becoming more comfortable
with recognizing Islam for what it is
I've noticed that things if I would have
said these things three years ago people
would have screamed Islamophobic but now
even some progressives are saying yeah
yeah it's a problem yes however here's
the biggest problem I think it's kind of
late already no I don't mean to be the
downer here or the negative girl but I
wish they would let you say it three
years ago
the reason I say it's already late is
look at Europe right almost gone and I
don't want to I don't want to sound all
negative but I don't think they can
easily take it back it's gonna take a
hell of a lot of work for Europe to go
back to what it was now we woke up in
America we started to you know let
things be and if you're not talking
about it at least we're not shutting
other people either but the reason it's
late is we are the last place for them
to take over right so our job is a
little harder it is a little harder and
so I want to take you back to you know
we talked about this and caught a lot of
flack when dr. ben Carson said no he
doesn't think that a Muslim could be
President of the United States he thinks
would be a problem because the Quran is
it can't really be put alongside the
Constitution that the two are
or unjustifiable as far as being put in
the face of each other in saleable yeah
it reconcilable sir i was looking for
the right word night my brain is just
mush because you know you put a pretty
lady on screen and then both of us are
dummies i don't know what happened did
you hear that and everyone said he was a
racist and he was a bigot did you hear
that and say well of course well I
actually when he did say that I was one
of the witnesses who went ahead and
signed his letter on the article he did
I was one of the people who signed his
his a statement as a witness well it's
one of those things that seems so
obvious like he said we need to ban
Sharia law well we have constitutional
law we have laws in the United States
which can't be reconciled with Sharia so
it seems like it's already banned but if
you say Sharia law needs to be banned
people go how dare you know it's it's
already banned many of the laws
individually well here you can't beat
your wife Sharia law says you can beat
your wife
therefore Sharia law is already illegal
but no it's not how many cases of honor
killings they'd be having United state
that the person walked away that's a
good question I don't know the answer
can you do we have for for like all or
last year no four in total since this
whole mass of Sharia law started
spreading in US okay we had four people
a father and a son a father a brother
and another father who actually killed
the girl in name of honor killing and
they walked away free based on cultural
differences was that the actual strategy
yes okay they wouldn't say like there
wasn't enough evidence to convict they
would if you actually look at the case
it was because of the cultural
differences culture yes good lord so you
can't you can't say sure you know he's
been here know it might be for us I mean
not even for me but it isn't for let's
say a woman who's yeah you have a lot of
Muslim woman who wants to leave and just
have a new life in here in u.s. and they
are scared of it we are actually working
on a shelter for them believe it or not
in u.s. they are afraid of leaving their
husband and leaving Islam because they
know
if they get killed nobody's gonna do
anything about it that's a cultural
difference well we are still having
Sharia law at the moment it's only
applying to Muslims right yeah exactly
and their goal is to apply it to all
non-muslims who they see as basically
Muslim apostate so we had a woman on
here we called her Q who had that
situation she had to be anonymous and
she's actually an American woman
American woman she was an American woman
who converted to Islam and left and she
basically couldn't let us know who she
was or she said they would take the kids
and she'd never see them again because
of the way as la mat courts would work
and there was nothing she could do about
it
so not afraid of being killed but she
said no that the law doesn't matter with
these cultures I would never see my
children again
so that is sad are you able are you able
to set up a shelter are you able to get
some of these women out or is it just is
it really hard because I've been
brainwashed for so long well it isn't
hard
one other thing live up to freedom does
we help people outside of America
basically we have had cases where we
rescued women from Islamic Republic of
Iran with their kid if they did have any
kids and we take him out you know we
smuggle out to other countries and they
go through the proper legal the steps of
you know asylum they get refugee status
they go to other countries inside u.s.
however we are struggling because our
own laws are working against us right
now because legally we cannot actually
hide these people right if they have
kids our law here says it's a kidnapping
so you see how it works so we don't have
the right to do that they're stopping us
from having we can get the paperwork
done to where we can actually rescue
children and woman from Sharia law
because to our love you're basically
kidnapping the kids right Wow
no luck here yet no I think that's
another example of sort of leftist
tolerance want to be pseudo
multiculturalism really hurting the most
defenseless among us when we're supposed
to be helping them in particular Muslim
women you know they always tried out on
Huffington Post a woman I'm a Muslim
woman and I love wearing the hijab and
that
there are feminists for Islam all over
campus and it really it really is sad
that it drowns out the voices of people
like you and people who are helping
listen we don't have on the schedule for
much more today will you come back on
the program because I want to get more
into your personal life story next time
can we do that absolutely well thank you
so much I appreciate where's the best
place for people to find you before we
go they can find us on a laptop if we
feed em calm and that's the best place
to find a section live up to freedom
calm and I bet you she's going to get
some suitors saying ham I'm a good
western male who will treat you
correctly but she's a nice lady don't
make passes online it's creepy ladder
with Crowder stay tuned
[Music]
[Music]
glad to be back I started dirt on you
with the shovel reticulum this is the
second hour to introduce you I am steven
crowder Lauda with crater comm producing
with me in video studio as always is not
gay jared who is not gay follow him on
Twitter at Nike Jared draw your own
conclusions I fulfilled my legal
obligations don't speak we're honoring
the middle east that's fair women are
not allowed to speak under Islam as you
just heard from Annie Cyrus her what's
your Twitter handle and Cyrus itself I
believe so like the name of the man who
arranged the whole meeting with the
Warriors in the park of the gangs can
you dig it
yes miss Cyrus we can well we're gonna
have jailed Morgan on Milda break we're
going to have a Firearms dealer to come
on to explain just for a segment exactly
what the process is like what kind of a
firearm this shooter used mm-hmm then we
will have Dave Rubin to talk about gun
control afterwards oh I almost forgot
Bob Ross teaches you how to draw
Muhammad that's incredible get that
right there it's incredible get we do
have some defendants Oh Bob Ross will we
want you to draw along with us live
scribe esta send us your best Muhammad
if you driven Muhammad's a driven if
you've written Muhammad send us your
best Muhammad okay still sense but go on
didn't what did I say written written my
brain is not in highest gear right now
okay we should do this probably right in
this statement okay so let's do this
we're going back to gun control Conan
O'Brien Samantha bee host of late-night
shows but of course Samantha bee got
most of the credit because she has a
uterus and so we all have to act as
though what she said in a cool leather
jacket and a cool leather jacket we all
have to act as though what she says is
is somehow more important or more
insightful but let's start with this we
want to go through some myths that you
may have been hearing on the late-night
show or just frankly some stupid
commentary let's start with Conan
O'Brien
these are weapons of war and they have
no place in civilian life I have tried
to understand this issue from every side
and it all comes down to this
nobody I know or have ever met in my
entire life
should have access to a weapon
that can kill so many people so quickly
and he gets that to thunderous applause
of course a couple of things weapons of
war so we're all the weapons even
according to your own argument back then
the muskets those were weapons of war
weapons of war change just like the ink
and quill became the printing press
became your iPhone
they've always been weapons of war
they've just evolved you don't know
anyone you've never known anyone who
might have one okay check the security
booth over there the TBS studio I've
been to the NBC Studios many times they
are armed to the teeth at the very least
they have semi-automatic pistols with
high capacities I think what are you
getting out of a out of a Glock double
stack nine millimeters at 17 I won't say
17 7 117 plus one and that's the most
common I believe Glock 19 isn't the most
common pistol for a popular pistol in
the world seventh Glock 17 would be the
most common now okay police please same
gun just a little bigger size a little
bigger size I'm still high capacity
thank about so Conan if you've never met
anyone I'm sure plenty of your friends
do they just don't talk to your arrogant
ass just ask security they have them all
around you there's a start okay let's go
to Samantha bee because everyone was
praising her let's roll the first clip
then the public decided that was no fun
Parliament passed strict gun laws and
they haven't had a mass shootings okay
first off there are more guns in
Australia than ever all right I have
this up on the screen gun-related
homicides there's an argument as to
whether it increased or not we brought
about this up at lotto with Grider calm
there wondering will have gun-related
homicides increased okay that's a debate
and some people say they haven't
increased but it certainly hasn't curbed
it dramatically you can use the term
mass shooting but most gun homicides are
not mass shootings here's something that
is undeniable
while gun violence went down violence of
every other kind every variety possible
in Australia went up there you go just
scrolling homicide sexual assault
robbery kidnapping
abduction look at this whereas in the
United States crime has gone down in
Australia it has skyrocketed who'd have
thought that taking away guns from the
good guys could result in people being
sitting ducks what a crazy thought so
when they point to Australia which by
the way it's all the very telling when
they point to Australia a mandatory
buyback is they come take your guns
that's not gun control capacity that's
they take your guns away so understand
that's what Samantha bee wants to do
here let's go to the next clip love you
Madison congratulations on your Tony but
you really [ __ ] us with that one we
can't constitutionally get rid of all
guns but can't we get semi-automatic
assault rifles out of the hands of
civilians a couple of things they always
use the term semi-automatic again
security at Samantha piece to do every
single firearm there's a semi-automatic
this is what will bring an FFL dealer on
afterwards you just know instantly how
dumb someone you know instantly this
person is a dumb ass and they don't just
say that flippantly like do because
you're liberal if you use the term
semi-automatic any basic self-defense
handgun is a semi-automatic as a matter
of fact most revolvers act as a
semi-automatic technically they're not
they're a double-action semi-automatic
means pull a trigger one trigger one
bullet now semi-automatic means that it
automatically reloads
the next bullet the chamber right racks
the chamber revolver does the same thing
it just doesn't need to reload because
the chamber switches over but
effectively it acts as a semi-automatic
one trigger Paul one bullet so when they
say that they're deliberately trying to
mislead you go to the next
[Applause]
yes I do want to take those guns away
these high-capacity penis substitutes
are a shitty choice for hunting and home
protection but perfect for portable
mayhem okay couple of things I love how
she uses slate right there an ironic
light you look at her and you look at
Conan and you look at that sorry Seth
Meyers slate slate lon
Mother Jones Vox just so you know when
these people claim that we're just
entertainers we're not biased right our
New Yorker what was it New Yorker
Washington Post these are the sources
I'm going to be using for you here
Washington she uses salon or sorry slate
on ironically that should be your first
tip-off right there um dad for home
defense bad for hunting Samantha bee
what have you done either of those
the reason the ar-15 which wasn't used
in this attack by the way it's so
popular is because it's very easy to
learn and very easy to fire for women
very low recoil very accurate very easy
very reliable hunting I'm not a hunter
I've seen people hunt with it is it the
most effective hunting rifle probably
not the more effective hunting rifles
would mow through 50 people that's
hyperbole at least five or six before
the round even stops the ar-15 is
effectively a glorified 22 with more
powder behind it okay it's not a big
round why because the United States
military they have the m16 variant which
is an automatic which is not legal and
let's have a class-3 license it's very
easy to shoot and keep on target because
of low recoil because it's not a super
powerful round so again she has
absolutely no idea you know it's a
crappy decision for all it's a great
tool for home defense something you've
never hunted shut up
next clip it turns up at gay nightclubs
movie theaters in elementary school
colleges even an office party with
coworkers it's nicknamed America's gun
and unlike handguns it can be bought in
Florida with no waiting period first
stuff that has nothing to do with
anything
many states don't have any waiting
period on handguns at all or rifles
again you're just sitting and it's not
using most mass shootings by the way the
ar-15 is not used the most rifles are
used in very small amount of homicides
certainly public mass homicides it's
almost always handguns which are just as
effective probably could have gone in
217 round magazines you could've had 25
round magazine and your handgun
replacing would have done the exact same
thing waiting period attention can you
talk about that we want to talk about
freedom you're a big strong woman right
you're fighting for feminist rights
here's a woman who died Carole brown
I've got it up on my screen you know why
she died because she was waiting to buy
a firearm to defend herself from a crazy
ex lover who got to her before the
waiting period was over here's the deal
I made it an ar-15 because of angry
Muslims don't like free speech mark
Stein Salman Rushdie I'm right there on
the careless next to them she needed it
because of an angry lover lots of people
need different firearms for different
reasons and you don't know those reasons
therefore you don't have the right to
infringe on their freedoms and their
right to protect themselves here's
something important many Americans live
20 minutes away from police departments
in this country okay 20 minutes away so
you can sit in your Upper East Side or
Upper West Side penthouse or your LA
apartment with your doorman building and
talk about gee how great you are even
though a woman's getting the hell raped
out of her down the block by a gang who
went into her house because they're 20
minutes away from a police call but you
did the tolerant thing people died
during waiting periods often when people
are buying firearms it's a necessity
next clip
so until we as a nation find the
political will to reject a mass shooting
per day as the price of freedom I'm just
gonna pray are you there God it's me Sam
please bless the victims and their
friends and families in their time of
unspeakable pain give us the courage to
say no more and while you're at it
please send the NRA a plague of boils oh
okay you let's talk about the NRA people
love to act as though there are like
Bernie Sanders and the Socialists we're
the party of the people in democracy and
lobbyists guess what the NRA is the one
organization in this country that is
largely funded by small individual
donations their biggest funder I have it
right here a hundred and seventy five
million dollars of the NRA s annual
budget and it is huge fifty percent of
that is from contributions 27 percent
comes from other donors the majority of
NRA funding comes from people who are
members okay so now when you were saying
the NRA you were talking about a huge
portion of American
a huge number of people here's something
else let me bring this one up for you
interesting you bring up the NRA because
you want to go to war against the people
who believe in protecting the rights
from elitist people like you in many
counts but this comes from the New
Yorker in many counts the power of the
NRA comes down to money organization
hears that it says but money is less
crucial than you'd think the NRA is
lobbying budget annually is three
million dollars which is about a
fifteenth of what say the National
Association of Realtors spends or big
unions where the the dues are mandatory
the NRA s biggest asset isn't cash but
the devotion of its members they're
politically active they don't even have
the money that big unions are big real
estate or big banks or big telephone
companies do but liberals want to single
them out because they are the
organization they are lobbyists as a
voice of the people who want to keep
their fundamental human rights
keep going to war with them Samantha be
you arrogant wench
[Music]
[Music]
breaking news a lower with louder
I'm very Matheson we take you to our on
the field reporter Jimmy in Orlando who
has interviews with families of the
affected victims after the horrendous
tragedy Jimmy yes Perry I'm here with
Eric who was actually in the club and
Eric thank you for taking the time we
know how hard this is
is there anything you can tell us that
maybe the media is not talking about
that could give us some some insight
into this situation and again we're
really appreciative of your time yeah
you know well the guy went in there and
obviously it was it was a horrendous
scene he continually kept yelling Allahu
Akbar and it's a tragedy all around
Jimmy but he just say the man was
yelling war know Perry that's not what
he said really clearly like that's what
is that no Perry he was yelling I love
my AR oh yeah we'll keep you abreast as
this story unfolds and when we gather
more for me holding the breath
[Music]
pull out old brother I'm Alison
[Music]
all right glad to be back with one of
our favorite guests great class quite a
bit all the time you know him he needs
to get a better Twitter handle though he
is a rocket scientist neurosurgeon no
one else he added what doctorate in
geology really do these billions off of
fracking and then just since the last
thing we had him on then made billions
off of lobbying against fracking so all
of these things G Morgan Jr at G Morgan
jr. on the the Twitter's Gerald Morgan
thank you for being with us sir
absolutely I think they call that
playing both sides I think well you're
hedging your bets
your there's money to be made everywhere
my friend very where there's money to be
made everywhere
not so much in apologetics and in
theology which is of course your your
main realm of expertise so we wanted to
have you on this week we had any Cyrus
just my god fascinating if you go back
and listen to a child bride sölden just
awful story yeah
but crappy upbringing that was a little
too close to the forest to see the trees
pretty pretty spunky pretty rambunctious
and she got pretty mad so Gerald's a
little more mellow so right now
obviously the move is to gun control
people are saying Islam has nothing to
do it jailed set it straight does Islam
have anything to do with Islam Islam has
everything to do with Islam I think I
think violence has a lot to do with this
slum and there's a lot of people out
there who ask that question does it
really is it really Islamic thing or is
it's just people that have perverted no
no it really it really is over a hundred
times
they're urged to be violent in the Quran
and in the hadith which is just think of
it like a Bible commentary except maybe
with a little bit more importance to
Muslims as a hadith and it's all now do
all schools of Islam use the Haditha
they consistently cuz some now say well
that's not the Quran that's a dthe
absolutely so it's basically like saying
there are five or six that are very well
respected and and kind of accepted
hadith so you can even quote from those
even if you want to limit the pool just
a little bit just to make sure
everybody's happy and you can quote from
those and be just fine but I've got I
mean literally right in front of me
right now I've got just list verse after
verse after surah after surah in the
Quran that talks about this and I will I
will concede something context as always
very important you're talking about
either biblical verses because you know
we're not supposed to be snake handlers
and see if we can survive a poisonous
bite or something like that
right but even if you take it in context
it still encourages people to go out and
commit violence even in the historical
context not only just the verses around
it but in the historical context as well
so a lot of people will say well no some
of the stuff that you're talking about
jihad isn't you know kind of an internal
conflict there's plenty of servers that
basically blow that right out of the
water because they're talking about
going out and fighting
if it's internal you don't really go out
I'd ask you this because I know we have
a lot we've done videos with these
verses but now the arguments that we get
it well there's also plenty there are
plenty of verses in the Quran that tell
you to love to not harm any innocent
people the grass especially which I find
yes Muhammad was very concerned with he
was I think the botanist though yes
ahead of his time who's ahead of his
time animals - you cannot scare a cow
with a knife I mean that's how that
whole goat rumor got stirred with an
ar-15 big that's totally okay right here
15 to scare the cat what do you say to
people who say that who would say and I
know this I think I know the answer to
it but I I know there's a very specific
philosophy behind it in the mainstream
schools of Islam because Muhammad did
say some nice stuff - absolutely but if
you are using those things - to say that
Islam doesn't promote violence in any
way shape or form you're just flat-out
lying by the way that is an acceptable
thing to do to infidels you can lie to
infidels and it's encouraged don't worry
about it there's also something called
abrogation where so you've got in the
Quran in surah - 2244 and 191 through
193 you've got certain things that are
being said here if he says something
later on say in 474 if he says something
different
it actually supersedes what he said
earlier and so you can quote from the
beginning kind of in the peaceful times
as kind of what they say in the
beginning of the Quran it's a little bit
more peaceful it's before he started
doing a lot of the stuff that we talk
about where there's a lot of warfare and
he's kicking people out of their own
villages and slaughtering and all this
kind of stuff and they'll say oh no this
is the peaceful part of the Quran and
they'll just quote those those passages
that help their cause they won't tell
you that later on things
it's kind of like the bow way time at
suffragette City you're talking about
changes and they wanted to ignore
everything after China girl or it's like
after labyrinth crystallizes Bowie in a
rough era that happened to maybe he was
just unstable and he was actually
transgender just was not understood
don't make a joke no no you can do what
everyone Muhammad but Bowie you're about
to cross some lines serious lines
because obviously he's passed by my
Bowie fan but there was some later
contributions to his catalogue that just
were frankly embarrassing but so it
would be like saying okay David Bowie
said ignore all my previous work erase
it because this is the work I need to be
known for that's the theology of Islam
right Mohammed was the quintessential
politician he spoke for whatever needed
to be said at the time to benefit his
cause so when everything was peaceful
and everything was cool I be peaceful
don't hurt the grass the cattle
everything else but when when all of a
sudden he's starting to be rejected and
he has to move into into another part of
the country he has to he has to go there
he starts to get a little violent he
starts to raid caravans so that he can
make money and then he starts to kick
the Meccan adversaries out of their own
city right completely did it got rid of
everybody so it's it says that there's
all I mean and you can read this it's
all throughout the internet even in
context guys look at the Quran it is not
a peaceful book at all
well ante historical accounts of maja a
theist like to say there's more
historical evidence of Muhammad than
Jesus and you know just because you're
telling it's one more recent but that's
not to say you don't throw the baby out
with the bathwater there are as
historical accounts of Muhammad not a
good guy
I mean this is not just from the Quran
historians acknowledge these things if
you if you could separate some of the
earlier stuff Muhammad did a reasonable
guy to kind of build your stuff off of
Europe you trying to build a religion or
trying to build some kind of a culture
not not all that bad it's when you get
kind of halfway through his life and his
ministry quote-unquote that thing starts
to radically change and it just shows
you the underlying character that was
always there that just didn't have an
outlet he didn't have a reason to kind
of bring it out when things were going
well but when rejection came he turned
into a really bad guy really fast not
the kind of guy that you want to have as
your pillar in faith right I said I'm
not the kind of guy I want
have as a pillar for the next-door
neighbor's faith that's all concern well
and I think that's something that people
are lying to themselves about they don't
know their own religions we've talked
about this a lot but the big thing that
you need to know is that in in the Bible
there are accounts of violence that
happened right there are difficult
passages within the Bible about
historical events sure in the Koran it's
left open-ended fighting is prescribed
for you and in the Quran - 2:16 that's a
different statement than saying David
went in and destroyed the Philistines or
whatever whoever he happened to be
fighting against at the time that's a
totally different statement right well
with this little break will bring you on
after this to be continued at him and
say much because it's very interesting I
was looking and he's a soothing voice he
should be in my seat here hosting I
don't know what I'm doing this I'm a
hack the guy's a neurosurgeon Gerald
Morgan Jr talking more about Mohammed
after this
[Music]
well there you are you're still here
you're watching this podcast on YouTube
likely did you miss the livestream
Thursday nights at 8 p.m. on YouTube or
Facebook either way you can also
subscribe on iTunes SoundCloud for the
audio version with additional
commercials and take it with you on the
go or louder with shredder comm which is
mobile-friendly so you can take it with
you wherever it's pretty cool in there
right hopper he likes it okay but you're
driving late enough
[Music]
gotta be back Joe more creepy about you
do that kid G Morgan jr. he was there
hey Gerald I want to ask you something
yes so this talk is Lomb putz has been
going back and forth but won't debate
we've had a rash of people refusing to
debate and I respect his act for coming
on and doing it but we had Michael Woods
jr. said no one would debate him and we
said you know what we can even say
debate we so we'll have you want to be
discussion to be productive he said sure
and now he is pushing out this GoFundMe
is the only way he'll come on
so he said Anytime Anywhere DL Hughley
moved to be fair I think he'll probably
come back on talked Islam won't debate
he talks about how Mohammed said do not
harm any innocent okay that and they
often use the term people of the book so
I don't want it we can't take super
along with this people of the book
gerald refers to whom people of the book
actually refers to christians so he's
referring to christians and essentially
jews by extension because he was he was
rejected by both of those communities
initially the thing you have to
understand though is that there's a
little bit of a fine line here you
either convert you pay the tax or you
die but in the very end you have to
convert or you die and that's that's all
throughout the quran again so right
there may be some verses that say if
these guys stop fighting against you
then you can leave them alone and there
are some and they'll quote those as
saying hey if these guys stop fighting
against us it was all defensive anyway
and that's not true right then we can
leave alone but that's not true it
actually involves conversion as well so
that it's only worshiping a lot if you
don't worship a lot in the end you get
killed look at every country in the
world that are dominated by Muslims
Christians can't just live there and
exist there's incredible persecution
they're treated horribly no your app
well you're absolutely right I wanted to
ask that because people of the book that
is true but like you said you go back to
abrogation not only that but well it's
it's one of those situations we're
talking with with
nice iris she she did enlighten us on
something she said you know they it's
not like Christianity or Judaism or
anything else where you convert to the
faith you're all seen as people born
Muslim and you were seeing an apostate
period and that is pump when you
understand that that's punishable by
death anywhere that's the one thing that
even most moderate Muslims a huge
portion you're talking hundreds of
millions believe in death for apostasy a
lot of them probably don't consider
everyone who's not Muslim an apostate
but that is the actual doctrine of Islam
that to me was fascinating and I think
people miss it again the context it's
kind of like the Second Amendment we
were talking about this earlier when
taken literally it's very clear when
taken contextually it gets even more
clear I feel like it's that way with
with Muhammad in the Quran you take a
Briscoe that seems really violent almost
look at the context like you said you
timeline matters abrogation matters
people of the book that term matters
they see everyone is apostate the more
context you add the worse it gets
exactly it just gets worse and worse
there are no innocence essentially
innocence basically refers to people who
believe in Allah the way they want them
to right everybody else falls outside of
that category like you said in there
apostates and therefore they're subject
to a completely different set of rules
as to how you treat them and I would
rather be grass at that point basically
Jarrell dressed as grass as Gumby it
really is troops one of those things are
so much misinformation that comes out
with this I'm amazed as to how quickly
we pivoted away from Islam at all and
right now in control it it frustrates me
and you to know and the first thing that
we're having to do is to talk to people
about the reason that it's a good idea
that we are armed as a population right
I understand or at least have the right
to to be armed and then Rolling Stone
comes out with this article if some
constitutional professor saying that he
should we should repeal the Second
Amendment it's time not to try to fix it
just to repeal it outright right and get
rid of it that we don't need guns and
I'm like man you're an idiot first of
all the biggest problem that we face on
this planet is radical Islam and not
even radical it's Islam the bigger
problem radical Islam as far as death
murder rates terrorism and then modern
Islam as far as abuse of human rights
yeah exactly I mean put those things
together and there really is no bigger
threat to society today and the thing
that you want to talk about is a scary
looking rifle and that's the problem
today one that wasn't even used exactly
just a ar-15 style granted it's you know
you can get to a technicality but it's
just it's very clearly weapon can we
call it what it is I always forget em
cxmc our MXC or whatever yes like that
very similar but ya know it's not what
what people would technically just say a
ar-15 but they want to repeat that ar-15
area 15 I just wish they would repeat
Muhammad and Mohammed in the verses so
people could know yeah all these people
hear the name ar-15 they know what that
is not a single one knows what sir is
not a single one knows what hadith is
not a single one knows who is none of
these people know and that is what is
it's incredibly alarming and it's it's
it really is I think there's rejection
as far as political correctness but the
media will go down kicking and screaming
we just Samantha be Conan O'Brien I
don't know anyone who would need that
kind of a gun well fine you don't I do
you know what I do I'm on Cara's list
mark Stein Salman Rushdie these people
are on lists where Islam Islamists try
to kill them they need an ar-15 and you
can't account for every single reason
why someone might need it so you have to
err on the side of freedom which of
course you have to come up with the
reason why I don't need it that's how
this works that's our essence of
freedoms work and they'll try they
definitely will but I think one more
thing to mention too is that when
President Obama came on and started
talking about the shooting
obviously the you and I we want to have
compassion for the people that had been
shot we want to care for the people like
second chair it puts a camera on
yourself stop yawning chair doesn't put
the camera on himself one time cuz he's
sitting near he's putzing around he's
yawning are you yawning you were selling
the Gerald oh there we go
Thanks I'm sorry he said he refused to
say the word Islamic terrorism and and
people called him out for that and he
came out with something that I thought
was better suited for a high school
cafeteria smackdown than any press
conference a president should ever give
and it was that these aren't these magic
words of this magic phrase that all the
sudden allows us to fight the problem
and I'm like you idiot it's like a
doctor walking in seeing you have a
broke
Armand saying you know you might have a
strain I'm gonna I'm gonna just give you
some Tylenol send you home you diagnose
the problem incorrectly and you can't
fight the problem right doesn't realize
we have an enemy and until you realize
you've have an enemy that is actually
trying to destroy you you can't fight
that that being said what you've just
said and we've talked about this is much
more nuanced I do get aggravated when
you hear other conservatives out there
is going why won't you say radical
Islamic terrorism they don't expand on
it's like that's not the point the point
is he won't say it why because he
doesn't want to acknowledge the problem
because he wants to appease these people
in our world standing as opposed to
actually upholding the Constitution but
people focus so much on so he's
wahlburger and then so then if he says
radical Islamic terrorism once your
argument goes out kind of like that's
the gun issue a good guy with a gun
would have stopped it well maybe maybe
not but that's not you can't because
guess what something you're gonna have a
story where a good guy with a gun gets
gunned down regardless and there goes
your argument that's not the argument
and so it makes it hard for people like
you and and what we do try and do on the
show to actually present why that
matters because you hear those sound
bites all the time what does music
tourism well he did the problems he's
not really acknowledging the threat
right it's it's that second part it's
the making sure that you diagnose the
problem correctly so you can fight it
that's why it's important it's not the
verbage or anything else it's probably a
couple guys you've hijacked the faith
and they're going that's not an
ideological problem that's worldwide
right spite you know even if you don't
have Isis next to your your little you
know desk right so okay how do you fix
it can you what's the Islam issue
because at some people say how do you
how do you deal with radical how do you
fix it I think the first step is is to
admit you have a problem I mean just in
any in a situation that you're in you
have to realize okay there's something
going on here it's not just random
violence it's not driven by the
economics of the region it's not driven
by global warming which some people say
not driven by a lack of resources lack
of water though it is hot and there's
little water over there but it is
actually an ideology that wants to see
us destroyed and it's a significant
number of people a very large portion of
the smiths population on the planet once
this country and others like us to go
away right and they're actively trying
to make that happen okay
first thing just admit that admit that
and then we can start taking the next
steps and going okay well what is next
how do we start to change
maybe our perception to some of these
people not not doing things that maybe
say I'm sorry for certain things that
have happened in the past that's not
what I'm talking about how can we do
things that show them they won't get
away with this here right how can we do
things that keep people that have these
kinds of ties from being able to get
weapons in the first place like this
what are you asking questions are you
gonna answer them well I'm not saying
that I have all the answers for the next
steps but we can't even go to these next
steps we've been asked these questions
then have great people great minds come
together here's the truth if now it is
possible for Islam to evolve you've seen
that with some religions even even if
they're getting away from the true
religion right you have some American
Muslims who have rejected that that is
true is it true Islam you can argue
probably not and of course compared with
everyone in the Islamic world no not
really
but there needs to be a civil war in
Islam and it can't be done without all
these people who clean there they are
this silent majority they need to stand
up and I'm not just saying you know
again it's very simplified when people
say well why don't you condemn the
terrorists who took you know and then if
a Muslim condemns it well then your
argument goes away talk Islam has yet to
condemn the terrorist attacks
twenty-five tweets and how great
Muhammad Ali was nothing on Orlando
right at the the point of this recording
it's not about condemning it it is we
need Muslims okay this is what you need
we need you to come not only condemn it
that's not it we need you to take up
arms join the militaries in our country
or the countries where you live to fight
against Islam just like people petition
their representatives to fight against
gun control or to fight against Flynt
tap water Muslims need to start electing
taking part in a political process and
pushing their representatives to fight
against Sharia law to fight against the
abuses of women and children that take
place right here on our own soil they
need to publicly reject and actively
fight against any sect that tries to
implement Sharia law they need to
publicly reject and actively fight
against any government that has death
for apostasy well what does that do that
means Muslims it's on you now to fight
Egypt to fight Turkey to fight a rant to
fight a wreck to fight Hamas oh that's
on you if you really have a problem with
it we need to see you know listen
bloodiest war in American history wants
to free the slaves right because people
had to say this is wrong
within our own ranks that needs to
happen with Islam they need some skin in
the game it's not just about saying will
you condemn this terrorist attack know
there needs to be a systemic approach
from Muslims to petition to protest to
politically and violently actively fight
this small contingency of Islamic cancer
spreading across what we need them to do
that otherwise it has to be nukes yeah
absolutely but here's the problem they
won't because the moment that they start
fighting against their own people they
become outside of that protected group
they've become infidels they become
apostates and therefore they can be
killed by everybody else so it's very
but that's more them no no I agree this
is what they should do but I'm telling
you why they won't right even people
that are in that kind of camp and say
yeah you're absolutely right we have to
stop these people that are that are you
know taking over our religion like they
said the protests over the drawing of
Muhammad how fast well why can't you get
that many Muslims in a Town Square why
can't you get that many to conduct it to
come together fight against a tear today
you can get them to come together and
fill the town freaking square because
someone drew Muhammad which we'll do
later on Bob Ross will be animal do a
live instructional and drawing Mohammed
but you can't fill the the the the the
be ballroom at the Hyatt with enough
Muslims for a terrorist attack let's be
real here one should be more outrageous
than the other and that's what it's not
just condemning a terror attack they
need to do what Americans and anyone
else in Western civilization does to
fight against radical Islam not just
they need to do that their citizen to
the United States you need to do these
things and I I don't hear anyone else
talking about that it needs it's not
just saying condemn the terrorist
attacks what I am saying is we cannot do
this without if there are as many
moderate Muslims as they claim as they
claim to have out there we need them to
do it they need to do it yeah absolutely
and to go biblical kind of on you you
judge a tree by its fruit sorry guys we
appreciate your words and you're sorry
for all the things that have happened
here but your fruit is telling us that
you stand for it because you're not
doing anything to stop it and in a lot
of cases you're promoting it especially
as organizations and leaders around the
world yeah they're high-fiving each
other on their back saying alright good
we're we're striking a blow at the enemy
and they look at us and they go oh those
freedoms that we hate that you have
guess what your politicians are now
coming out and saying we need to get rid
of the Second Amendment or we need to
get rid of these guns we need to
restrict freedom we need to restrict
freedom of speech bring in Syrian
refugees let men into the little girl's
room and disarm all women what could
possibly go wrong
Gerald Morgan at G Morgan Jr thank you
so much brother for being with us left
have you back soon
absolutely but thanks thank you very
much that was Gerald Morgan he's a
rocket scientist neurosurgeon and now
geologist just got another degree I'll
notify after the break what it is
[Music]
for breaking news and water with Crowder
I'm Perry Madison we take you now back
to Orlando with Jimmy our on the street
reporter who has exclusive interviews
with those affected from the horrendous
tragedy this week limit yes Perry thank
you I'm here with Patrick Patrick thank
you we're really sorry that we even have
to ask you for this interview we want to
try and help best prevent this tragedy
in the future through accurate reporting
and aggregation of information is there
anything that you think maybe the media
hasn't accurately addressed was there
anything there you can tell us well yeah
it was obviously horrendous was a
tragedy and I mean the man came in and
obviously was uh had some bad intentions
and he repeatedly yelled there is no god
but Allah and Muhammad is His Prophet
and you know that sends shivers done
everyone's fine no no no it sounded like
he said let the mass murderer yell there
is no god but Allah Muhammad is His
Prophet no Perry your headset must not
be working again there's nothing like he
said there was no god but Allah Muhammad
no he said he's tired of all these gun
manufacturers making obscene profits oh
interesting to say the least well you go
to the bottom of this and breaking news
waterless crowd I'll keep you abreast of
the story on the floor
I am buried on the hood
[Music]
glad to be back little and ewk for you
nothing wrong with that have a guest
someone who has directly been vilified
in media not really more so the idea of
this person he runs Patriot pawn and gun
calm guess what you can purchase there
guess what your car that Alex joy joins
us can you hear me sore I can are you
there Crowder from the store right now I
am I'm live in the store we got
customers at the counter we're selling
guns right now that's is that is that
illegal it is in Idaho well I just you
know I don't know if someone feels that
a background check or something in their
social security number is seen over your
shoulder okay so you how long have you
been in a business the firearms business
Alex I've been in the biz for nine years
I'm a Federal Firearms License older and
I have a you know I've got a license
from the federal government's that says
I can legally sell guns okay so let me
ask you this because they're a few
rumors and so I wanted to get someone
with direct experience it's up now
Patriot Patriot well we'll get Patriot
pawn and gun calm can people purchase
online
we don't sell directly online but they
can contact us and we can transfer
firearms we can make the sale here right
and we can transfer to another Federal
Firearms License holder in their state
okay exactly well I wanted to get to
that because I wanted to make sure so
people can go to the site or wherever it
is and check it out because are a lot of
a few logical fallacies here can someone
purchase a firearm you're at you're a
firearms dealer legally from you without
a background check does that happen
absolutely not big no-no okay we gotta
run them through a very stringent
process I mean the money for all gun
dealers it is it is there's this
mythology out there that the anti-gun
left uses that it's you know so easy to
get a gun legally it's not now you can't
get a gun easily
legal illegally because we've got a
horse up in southern border and you got
drug cartels and gang members going back
and forth with the legal guns all the
time you go to Detroit Chicago LA
anyplace downtown and buy a illegal gun
and it's easy so you can buy some meth
or some crack cocaine yes you can our
bath salts and bite somebody's face off
although actually they weren't even on
bath salts
I don't dish dish it into you they had
just smoked pot people don't realize
that few of them they were just everyone
was filing Bassel okay so they can do
that mist or
online like you just said you ship to
another FFL check online because they
say you can buy online without a
background check again we're talking
illegal no ok what happens is so they
may order a gun online from store a
store a has to ship the gun properly and
again there's a lot of rules and
regulations Patriot pawn and gun calm
let's use yours as an exist so let's say
someone says I want to get I don't know
I want to get a Glock 19 from you from
Patriot yeah so they order from me they
they go to patriotic gun calm they call
us up we sell them a Glock 19 I have to
then get from them Federal Firearms
License copy from the FFL agent on their
in their city from there in I have to
ship directly to effect another Federal
Firearms License holder and then they go
pick up the gun from that FFL dealer and
they have to go through the 4473 process
the strict background check and all that
to get the gun right okay now I know
this but a lot of people a lot of people
out there who haven't purchase firearms
don't know the process and that's the
beauty of the of the firearm issue all
it takes is someone having bought one
firearm ever and they know Hillary
Clinton is lying they know it that's not
absolutely okay so so people are
complaining this shooter you know well
why wasn't there a longer waiting period
or something talk about like which
firearms do have a longer waiting period
or people use the term fully automatic
turns out the guy didn't even use an
ar-15 he used was a six-hour MC a six
hour I think it was a MPX it's basically
a kind of a fancy pistol actually a
high-capacity fantasy pistol okay so
that looks a little bit like a like a
like an SBR a short-barreled rifle well
why do they say ar-15 style why do they
always is it just because they want to
repeat that drill it in to make people
afraid of the name cuz this isn't the
bogeyman
that's the bogeyman and the reality is
that less than 300 people are killed by
a rifle per year in the United States
and of those maybe a hundred a hours a
year I mean out of a nation of 300
million people I mean you're the odds of
you you know directly you drowning in
your swimming pool are much greater than
getting shot by an ar-15 sure okay so
but it's it but it's a buzz word you
know right so Eve black gun well you can
also get them in green you can get them
in pink I know it's true a pink gorgeous
yeah
there are now gay gun clubs online there
they're called like pink guns groups
that are arming up and getting trained I
love it and they're they're a ours
you're pink
well I'll hopefully they realize their
enemy are not Christian gun owners that
it's it's still Islam because I want to
throw them off the roof or go shoot up
absolutely you know some of the
evangelical 's don't want to bake them a
cake but you know for rude it's
comparable shoot them once the shooter
Makram off the building you know they're
comparable yes analogical Sally Kohn
makes a convincing argument the
similarities are striking okay so air
fifteen I know it's not fully automatic
people know now from a class to dealer
they're not fully auto they're called
semi-automatic requesting dealer like
myself okay so what is required to get a
fully automatic weapon that's a class
three license so again I want people to
know when they say fully automatic
what's required to get that in what
class is it sure let me show you real
quick with the difference between a
class two and a class three is okay see
this switch right here okay there are
two positions on a class two semiotic
automatic there is safe and there is
fire right now when you put it on the
fire switch it's just as fast as you can
pull your trigger but it's semi-auto
it's every trigger pull shoots one round
a full auto like what our troops are
shooting has a happy switch you go one
more position that way and then it's
full auto you you tug the trigger and
it's right rapidly sitting and that is
clap that requires a class-3 license
wire it's a class three license it's
very difficult to get a class three
license far more difficult than any
other government regulated thing known
to man right it can take six months to a
year to get a class three license you've
got to go to a class three dealer you've
got to go through a stringent background
check where they practically do a enema
and rectal exam on you yes then you wait
and you wait and you wait you wait
what's the mandatory when you're 55 I
think anyway yeah I mean it would take
me a half hour to explain the process
but varies by what yeah we don't need to
explain the full process because we only
have one minute left but I wanted people
to know a lot of you out there just here
semi-automatic the wordplay is important
I want people to how hard it is to - let
me ask you this real quick just twenty
seconds is there any firearm law that
could have prevented this absolutely not
you can't prevent you know that guy's
gonna get
and if they don't get a gun they're
gonna get a knife they'll get a knife
they're gonna set the place on fire
they're gonna do evil they made a you
know those guys in Boston made made a
bomb out of a pressure cooker and some
nails and some gasoline I mean come on
then go down to Home Depot what do you
get banned Home Depot I had a great
unkind guys from a pressure cooker but
Alex I hate to cut you a patriot pawn
and gun calm right
yes sir part of gun calm summit firearms
Academy get armed get trained you're
gonna thank you you got to protect
yourself get trained Patriot pawn and
gun calm but don't go asking them for
machine guns because you can't do it out
looks enjoy thank you very much for
educating us sir will what we'll make
sure to educate people more after this
now go now go now put up
you
and now for actual studio conversation
[Music]
dog is a weird economy earlier you just
you're just licking himself like he just
could not get enough of his downstairs
nether region I just you just sounds
like the least half an hour that's
what's in there
it is weird I told you know dogs weird
no you're weird what he's a dog a dog
licking himself as natural you watching
him for 45 minutes is not at all this
has been actual studio conversation
[Music]
glad to be back our weed the third our
third our we are in a third our sorry
people listening on the stream they're
going what do you mean third our because
we cut it shorter than those listening
on radio by the way no big announcements
we're never we're not going daily don't
try and force our hand and we're just
stop stop Trudy can just rude to insist
on this show will never go daily we do
not have an exploratory committee there
are no plans in the works shut up your
host steven crowder producing with me in
video studio as always is not gay Jared
follow him at night so we have something
for our viewers right now I'll treat
those listening on radio of course right
now with the Islam issue people are
saying well is Muslims are not peace
hating terrorists and of course that's
the case you're saying Islam is not a
problem and Islam is entirely compatible
with Western culture the problem with
Western culture is guns and Muslims
support freedom of speech as any one
doesn't so we know that we are that for
example you can speak out exact time you
can convert you can fight against Sharia
of course freedom of speech you can draw
Mohammed and so we actually found this
one you may not have seen this before
kind of got buried it kind of got Barry
kind of like long-lost historically I
don't think people were on at archives
law alert it wasn't archived well at all
but thank God for YouTube we have Bob
Ross your favorite public broadcaster
amazing painter and we found this
episode of the joys of painting where he
teaches you how to draw Mohammed let's
do it
[Music]
I welcome to joy of painting I'm happy
to see you here today especially on this
week cultural appropriation month as we
appreciate the wonderful culture that is
the Middle East and Muslim friends it's
always good to have friends of many
different walks of life so today we're
gonna be teaching you how to draw a nice
picture in a landscape of Muhammad peace
be upon him the holiest of prophets so
let's show you how to start you got to
get your paint ready I prefer to use
oils you could use pastels it's whatever
you pick painting can be easy for
anybody let's just pick a nice neutral
color and we are going to just start
drawing Mohammed a little prophet they
will let me grab the color there we go
just give him a body a little bit of a
body there Sikh doesn't have to be
complex traditional headdress they wear
in the Middle East let's give this let's
give this man a beard
there we go nice beard for Mohammed and
protect your face in the sandstorms
beard is important to have and there we
go give him some facial features see
little details see how that fills out
the picture now Mohammed though look at
him he looks lonely how about we give
him a wife let's just draw him little
wife favorite one was Ayesha a little 6
year old wife right there we'll put her
in the jab not the full burqa you can
choose your favorite color for the head
jab her burka can be black or slate and
little six-year-old Asia you know what
let's give her a knapsack she's about
that age where she'll go to school
Ayesha Muhammad's favorite wife was six
nine when he consummated she was a good
student and a tender love her look at
that see look very quickly of Ayesha
Mohammed what a cute couple
but he still seems a little lonely let's
give him a few more wives just a few
more wives these ones don't have to be
complex can you can use black
hooray let's give them the full burqa
there you go and a couple more wives
just a couple more wives to keep him
company one two three
of course he had more you can draw as
many as you want use the color you want
Mohammed lacked some foliage let's draw
some trees for him I'm using a forest
green you could use a you could use a
military green because he was a warlord
killed lots of Christians and Jews
didn't like him very much
there we go just some foliage some trees
let's give some there on the other side
of Mohammed there let's get just a
little bit of green oh that's nice see
Mohammed was really clear that should
never hurt the trees and the time of war
was very concerned with the plants not
so much with his wife so let's give
Ayesha a little bit of a black eye I
think that's her next step
Mohammed of course did strike a shoe but
only lightly causing her great pain
let's put black either I'm using moe you
can use violet you just want to make
sure people see the severe beating
Ayesha took you know what let's get our
crimson red in there give little
six-year-old Ayesha a student lover of
fat lip
that's Muhammad's wife who he be he's
drawn right there so you can see the
left of her and there we go Ayesha with
a black eye and a fat lip oh look at
that picture out there in the desert
lonely nights the finest even look what
we were able to draw here just a couple
of minutes painting doesn't have to be
hard especially when your inspiration is
Mohammed the holiest of prophets who
like to beat a six-year-old wife didn't
her trees but I had lots of lives didn't
like Jews I hope you've enjoyed it have
a good week and happy painting
[Music]
yeah that's nice it's good to just
lighten it up every now and then it was
I was really glad we found that not
political just teaching people how to
paint paint hobbies are getting back to
the simple joys of life
speaking of simple joys we didn't we
don't updated this in a while let me
give you a macro from the left they want
to employed Syrian refugees from
war-torn lands and record numbers they
want to send your women in with men in
the restrooms and entirely disarm
everyone what could possibly go wrong
there we talked about the the cost of
freedom I have this up on my screen
ladder with Grider calm for those of you
listening to rest really we started
compiling a refugee hit list and then we
stopped it just got to be too long but
to give you an idea some things where
maybe being armed might have helped
Germany Syrian refugee assaults 30 old
woman Germany Syrian refugee arrested
for assaulting children UK fool of in
the UK full of British schoolchildren
were attacked by migrants who smashed a
window and caused a child as separate
epileptic fit Muslims attacked Germany
to attack Germans and German cash my
mouth is just attack eight months
pregnant old women in Germany because
she was wearing a cross Norway three
year old boy raped by multiple people at
an asylum Center German leisure centre
becomes the first to ban all migrants
after school girl was sexually assaulted
in a public swimming pool of course you
have the Boston bombers of course you
have the Paris attacks so I just want to
give you an idea as to what an actual
threat is if you want to talk about
something consistent let's talk about
Islam not only the violation of not only
the violation of life not only terrorism
but violation of basic human rights as
well and Human Rights doesn't mean the
right to get a gay wedding cake it
doesn't mean the right to get married
anywhere you want and any Church you
want outside of a civil union from the
government I'm talking about fundamental
rights like life not being raped being
able to defend yourself those don't
exist in many countries in Europe that's
kind of important so I wanted to talk
something here we're going up Dave Rubin
after the break have a lot of affection
for Dave Rubin I'll explain why because
he doesn't do what's happened with a lot
of other leftists
deal Hughley was supposed to been the
show then he had to cancel to be fair DL
Hughley has come on before he did say
he'll do it next week jill Sobule who
was working did the songs for bernie
sanders agreed to come on she didn't
come on we've had we've had a rash of
this lately to this week a big one
Michael Woods jr. who was on the Joe
Rogan podcast who was on there talking
about the Second Amendment wanting to
remove the Second Amendment rights for
many people said no Joe said well why
don't you have learned-- you do a
debates at all no one will do it sam
harris turned me down he said no one
will debate him no one will do this with
him and i said okay well listen i'll do
it
love to love to have a discussion with
you i think it'd be productive i used
the word discussion he said sure so this
is what he want to give you this because
we were going to have him on the show a
lot of you were excited and let me say
this to start off with i have an immense
amount of respect for joe joe rogan i've
done his show and i don't just say that
as a hollow sort of compliment i can
tell you exactly why I respect him I
disagree with him on a whole lot
trailblazer with not only comedy the
style that he does but podcasting going
alternative with that really building up
a podcast from scratch I remember when
he used to do it with a webcam really
basic with with Joey Diaz because my
friend John lost what was on and he
created it he went off on his own and
also has been immensely successful
starting a bet or working with a
business on it supplement company with
his podcast came in to UFC obviously one
of my favorite sports when he really
wasn't being compensated all that much
because he loved the sport he's a guy
who's just done what he wants to do he
lived his life independently I truly
have a lot of respect for Joe even
though I disagree with him so I want to
make sure that if Joe was out there
occasionally he might listen or watch
some of this I didn't want to hijack his
show that's why I offered my platform I
don't ever want to assume or leverage
this program to try and force Joe's hand
so I said let's do it invited him on our
program this guy Michael Woods jr.
accepted here's the image of Michael as
jr. saying no no that's the that's the
private email the image from him of the
tweet we'll get to the private email the
tweet where he said sure let's do a
Skype call or a pre record we have that
yes you said all right we'll see what
joe says and if it doesn't work we can
do a recorded Skype or something my DMS
are open so let's go to the dm's we said
hey do we have you on this week he said
he was traveling from the coast
when he got back so we said okay that's
fine you let me know when be well and
you can see this up here Jade will bring
it up on screen then he went public and
changed the conditions and said new
terms I'll debate steven crowder when he
eat and put up some GoFundMe and then
behind the scenes told me to act
professional when he had moved the goal
posts but you got these direct message
here because I want to read it for the
audience he said that's not a debate
what WTF do you not get a debate is
controlled moderate it doesn't even make
sense he can't write clearly but he
basically kept changing the goalposts
he's not coming on for a debate and he
was the one who accepted he was one who
said no one would debate him it seems
like he just wanted to use this to
leverage to get back on Joe Rogan's
program it's really hard to get liberals
we agree we said no time limits no
editing we do that with people and I'd
say seven times out of ten they just
back out and it's been a real problem so
we tried to bring it to you hopefully he
comes on I don't think he has any intent
of doing so but we have Dave Rubin after
the break he's a good one stay tuned
you
oh there you are again I'm glad you're
enjoying the videocast or live video
stream but many of you don't know you
can subscribe on iTunes or SoundCloud
take the audio version with you on the
go
there's exclusive commercials plus it's
free as we know you don't want to say
cheap inexpensive your frugal stay still
hey Steven what are you doing
yeah I'm just browsing air 15.com give
me the side about scared like rifle with
the best prices community and
information on the web now what the hell
is a difference hey yeah 15.com ar-15 a
calm air 15 a calm you know they just
heard the three tapes
you did three tapes you didn't edit it
they can hear you
[Music]
glad to be back guile street fighter
theme song makes everything better
absolutely and I'm glad to have our next
guest I have to say this right off the
bat before we bring him on I have a lot
of affection for him I really like the
guy I have a soft spot in my heart from
because we disagree on a lot I think
he's a good guy I think he's a stand-up
guy
he's one of the few people I haven't
spent a lot of time with whom I trust
character wise and he's willing to
actually show up and stand in the pocket
with people even if it disagrees with
them so again you never want about
hollow compliments I'm in the business
of actually describing why you can
follow him on Twitter at Rubin Report or
his wonderful YouTube channel with his
talk show Dave Rubin thanks for being
with us brother was that 16-bit street
fighter it was yeah so it was super
street fighter guile song I wasn't
exactly sure what it was but I knew it
was 16-bit something or other so that's
beautiful to come into that I have Sega
Genesis in the other room right now
pretty speech and blah blah blah but why
don't we just start one of these video
game channels and we'd be written
rolling and we'd be millionaires but I'm
a super nintendo guy so we'd have you
know that's the white privilege of the
the console wars you know it's funny I
can accept a lot of your radical racist
positions the Super Nintendo thing that
I can't get oh really get just go it
really gets this note it's like alright
you don't like trans people you know
what it's like really super nintendo
ever Sagan isn't well it makes sense
I mean you know there are more buttons
but I guess I guess Dave Rubin he
doesn't like as much variety with the
buttons that's why he stays with his own
buttons Dave stop it not gay Jarrod oh
thank you for explaining to me via text
out of tweet before I get on the show a
lot of notice forget a lot of you just
forget I just wanted you to so that way
you have the link and you could just hit
retweet you know if the fashion your own
tweet you should be thanking me this
just is this so you just pay see I
compliment him and he's just petulant
just nothing about perpetuating the
original stereotype Dave this likes to
[ __ ]
stop the basketball game for this song
just God ha I'm missing it it's a
basketball game in Los Angeles I'm sure
they cower in fear when Ruben shows up
pickup ball to both like NBA so
that'sthat's incoming so okay Dave we
had a listen I mean I know you're not
really super liberal you're kind of
moderate you're very reasonable but all
of our liberals have dropped out and so
I said listen I need you to come in and
pinch-hit and I think you and I slightly
disagree on the gun control issue let me
ask you this this has happened this is
unfolded this week okay you're a
reasonable guy you're more moderate
you're also gay I don't think it's any
secret I know you don't you don't you
don't dine off of that was your reaction
right away
we have a problem with Islam it's up in
the air depending on who you ask so I
say that because it's obviously this
affects the gay community and there's
been a very big outcry from both the
left and the right and it seems like
they're just kind of we don't even talk
about that today because I never want to
use the gay community as pawns what was
your reaction did you go to Islam's a
problem or oh my gosh gun control all
right well there's a couple things here
so first of all I would only say in
every case of this whether this person
had turned out to have been a white
Christian or a brown Muslim or a Asian
gay person or an eighth you know a
handicapped Indian or give me a couple
others I would always blame the person
who did it first right the means with
which they do it look if I had a machine
gun it okay so they were originally they
were saying was ar-15 but now I guess
it's something else it's not right but
AR 15 isn't a machine gun either okay a
six-hour mcx to someone like to someone
like you who hasn't probably fired
either you would think they're very
similar it's a different operating
system okay fair enough
so we'll illustrate my point even more
right if I had
here right now I would not think my god
I have that done here I should go into a
gay club and shoot gay people or I
should go into a mosque and shoot
Muslims or I should go into you know a
church and shoot Christian people so it
is not about the gun itself now we can
have a debate about some level of gun
control and it's a too easy for people
to get guns which shouldn't get guns and
that kind of thing but I always would
blame the person who did it from the ice
ology that made them do it and I and
this is again I mean this is where we've
really come together and why I have male
friends that I consider on the right
that I'm happy to have friends we have
to talk about bad ideologies and we
can't be afraid to and there's one
ideology that they hold above all of us
and it's the one that would love to have
me killed gay is jus not doing that well
either no to talk about it I mean you
know okay
but you know I know exactly so that's
why I asked because listen do you think
the gay communities wait listen there's
a war with Islam there's not a war with
Christianity the bathroom thing here's
the thing it is an entirely tenable
position for a Christian er many atheist
to say okay I think you should use the
bathroom to your biological sex we have
some issues with it that is an entirely
tenable position without hate you can
argue the science of it and say they're
wrong doesn't mean they hate somebody it
is not a tenable position to say gays
need to be killed or treated as
second-class citizens as they are in
every Islamic country depending on how
you add up the Islamic countries there's
about 51 of them it depends if you talk
about Muslim majority countries or
countries where it's really more into
the government governmental level etc
but in all of those countries it's
pretty horrific for gay people it's
pretty horrific you know what I mean
like you can major vdl gay somewhere and
not only that but then in most of these
countries too because they treat their
women hardly and how and the women as
Bill Maher says the women have to wear
beekeeper costumes in some of these
countries well if you're if you're
ellipsis pretend you're a gay man in one
of these countries or you're a
heterosexual man and you're young and
you can't look at women if you're
straight and you can't look at men if
you're gay you can't act on that impulse
well as Bill Maher says that's fertile
ground for terrorists
and I think that's a great way of
looking at it if you can't get out your
most natural human impulses guess what
people like to have sex
straight people like to have sex gay
people like to have sex everyone likes
to have sex that's just one part of
being human it's a very human thing
right and if you can't get those
impulses out and then at the same time
you're listening to Imams and creatures
who are demonizing gay people and of
course demonizing Jews and Israel and
all that stuff well guess what it's a
perfect combination right this guy who
is American who internalized his
homophobia turned it on himself and then
who did he kill he kill gay people
because his religion taught him not
exactly okay we have to go to a break
and then we will bring you back after
the break I don't know what kind of
16-bit we have after this I don't know
but hopefully there's something good and
then we'll talk about the gun control
where we disagree because people want to
hear that we need a little bit of it at
least laterals Crowder's stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
for bragging mills on louder with
Crowder I'm Carrie mathison's we take
you again to on the field reporter Jimmy
in Orlando in the wake of this tragedy
with exclusive interviews to get to the
bottom of the incident and ensure that
no tragedy like this occurs again juhi
yes Perry thank you I am here with Gene
thank you so much for taking the time
and we really want to do our job as
journalists responsibly and try and
mitigate this kind of a tragedy in the
future do you think that there's any way
or anything that we've missed that you
heard in the incident when you were
there well you know I can just reiterate
what other people were telling you that
he was yelling out allahu akbar that the
man was clearly unstable and repeatedly
every time he was he was being involved
in a violent altercation yelling out
that muhammad is the holiest of prophets
peace be upon him no no no Jimmy it
sounded like he kept yelling Mohammed is
the holiest of proffers feasts we Apollo
no Perry that's not what he said no what
he said was the shooter liked McDonald's
and had a piece on him he had a piece on
a piece is a term he's african-american
it's the term they used for firearms he
had a piece on him no Jimmy that is
patent bull you're full of it you're
gonna do your job jelly I am doing my
job I won't let you take this with your
bigotry
well what bigotry like man just gave you
what the they are sale all actually flat
so what you think just because he yells
out Allahu Akbar and muhammad is his
only prophet or peace be upon him you
think that somehow means that this is
islamically related Jimmy you are a hack
you are just the pets the absolute pets
and I'm a shame is here time
we'll keep you abreast and the story
unfold cloud give me a rope track
[Music]
glad to be back follow this man watch
his show youtube.com slash Reuben report
hey dave rubin what's going on with your
show real quick before we continue
holy cow Crowder what a what a week so
you knew you were one of the few people
who were on the inside you knew what was
happening three weeks and you know I can
keep a secret now finally because I have
a couple other things I want to tell you
some of them should be directed at not
gay Jarrod some of them I can I was with
or a TV since September which has been
great it's Larry King's digital network
they've been great to me the fact that
Larry King the Kay the true king of talk
thought that I was someone that was
worthy of bringing in has been amazing
to me but I decided over the last couple
weeks it was just time to own my thing
I've seen what you've done I've seen
what guys like Joe Rogan have done and
Adam Carolla and a couple other guys and
I was just like my audience is there now
I know what I'm saying the fact that I'm
doing this from the left as the left is
crumbling there's a space for me and I
wanted to try it on my own so we're
going the fan funding route as of this
week and we started on Monday and right
now we're I think as as of a few minutes
ago we're at 18 grand a month already
which is awesome and it's just from the
fans and and I'll be beholden to my fans
and I'll just keep saying what I think
and it's pretty sweet
so Larry Kings still alive that's cool
where can people go if they wanted this
cuz honestly people if you're listening
Ruben report you can you can just even
give him a couple bucks a month I highly
recommend it the guy does good stuff he
comes in the show he's had me on his
show even though a lot of his audience
at the time hated me where can people go
and by the way not only that you've also
been to the studio I think you're the
only one that was that was a deal
operation right there but you can go to
Ruben report.com / donate or patreon.com
slash Ruben reporting all the stuffs
there and you get all kinds of you know
we do one-on-one skypes and all kinds of
fun stuff if you want to jump in on that
try and it's cool you know I'm grabbing
a hold of my of my operation which is
what you've done and and I think I
really think that's the future of this
whole thing but real quick yeah Larry
King Larry not only has been great to me
but now I'm invited to his morning
breakfast he has that he has his old
crew of guys they do
five days a week and they talk sports
and they talk politics and they fight
and they argue and they tell jokes and I
went a couple times last week it's just
great it's like it's like roll a casket
with Larry wherever he goes as a pro
bono come on he is a great man he you
know what it will imagine if me you Milo
Dave Roman the whole a Jew correct
all right that's how his interviews go w
casein Andrew W K there's a rumor that
you're not real and that was it you
didn't even ask why
but imagine imagine us in 30 in the for
30 years imagine us in 50 years doing
what we're doing right now but you know
having breakfast while we're doing yeah
yeah okay so but I want to get to we
said we might have some disagreements on
gun control real quick because I don't
have a ton of time what is your position
on this you're saying keeping the guns
out of hands of people so I just want to
hear your position if you can surmise it
in like 30 45 seconds we can get down
the trail deconstruct well I didn't say
keeping guns out of the hands of people
I yeah there are certain people who
shouldn't have guns everyone knows that
if you're on the terrorist watch this
you shouldn't have a gun I mean that's
you know I pretty sure you agree with me
on that no you don't agree with me if
you're on the terrorist watch list you
should have a gun okay what about the
no-fly list are you including that
because people use them interchangeably
as well right so I know there's a
difference between the terrorist
watchlist and a no-fly list so without
getting a huge difference you can be put
on and there's no appeal there's no due
process and there's no way to get off
and they remember Napolitano said that
right-wing Christians should be flagged
for as domestic terrorists anyone can be
put on anyone has been put on without
due process and this guy wasn't on it
so what results in time so you're
boarding a flight you're the flightless
bomb in the terror list I don't know
well not only was this guy not on it but
he was on other FBI watch lists and they
totally dropped the ball on it so you
know I'm not gonna come in here and
defend the government right they took
them off right but that proved that me
that's proving my point that you know
these guys are pretty inept anyway so
right so my point is you can't use the
terror watch list or no flatus it
doesn't mean anything so I would say
this look forgetting the nitty-gritty
which we can't solve in 30 seconds I
would say that if you if your issue is
guns
you at the very least have to have an
honest discussion about Islamism but if
the left won't have an honest discussion
about Islamism then guess what you're
never gonna have the discussion about
guns there's a legitimate debate an
honest debate to have about guns and I
probably am somewhere more to the left
than than you on that I think there's
some control that would make sense but
I'm not absolutely for the Second
Amendment I believe people have the
right to bear arms right but that being
said if you just never let people have
the honest discussion about a doctrine
that literally says kill you as the
non-believer and kill the gays right and
subjugate women and all of that stuff if
you're not even allowed to talk then you
can't then you can't tell those people
to take away their guns so I understand
your people like we agree on that and I
just I need I need to get to some of the
disagreement because you are filling in
for a coward who refused to come on the
show so we need someone to so I need to
do this I'm not trying to be mean but we
just every left us drops out and you're
far more reasonable but let's just
pretend you're not so the terror
watchlist and no-fly lists doesn't mean
anything right let me ask you this is
genuine okay because I genuinely think
that people in lausanne I was just on
the phone with Google with people over
there in Google's the executive offices
and I asked her I said do you have a gun
she said no I said have you ever known
anyone who's purchased a firearm you
said no I've never known anyone who's
needed one and that is such a bias that
people don't understand they can't
possibly know so I don't say this to say
you're stupid but I do think that most
people in California particularly the
big cities are incredibly ignorant when
it comes to firearms and they need to be
educated and that's why I say matter of
fact I'm buying you a gun I'm buying you
a gun - Avery but I'm gonna send it to
you so you can see what the process is
like because people who've never
purchased a firearm yes I will do it
people who've never purchased a firearm
you can have to go through so much
paperwork you'll never believe again
that people are just buying guns
willy-nilly let me ask you this once I
like the idea of you buying a gun but I
just the paperwork do I have to do the
paperwork good that's the point and
we'll have you videotape it because
these people are going out acting like
there's no paperwork no background check
okay but when I say send sending out
you're Jewish you should love paperwork
you know I say semi-automatic yeah what
do you what do you think what does that
mean so I'm not a I'm not a gun
aficionado so this is I don't say it to
make you sound stupid and be like -
asking me what
to the carburetor is I wouldn't know
right i right so when someone says
semi-automatic to me my sense is that
with a semi-automatic you can press once
and you're gonna get a certain amount of
rounds out and that is basically a
semi-automatic one only one one round
one round one trigger pole one round
that's every gun outside a bolt-action
or pump action right so I said because I
said a certain amount of rounds so if we
ran again I don't I'm not at all trying
to install you so don't think this is an
ambush but you say a certain amount of
rounds you probably thought right when I
say semi-automatic maybe burst fire
not sure yeah that's not that's not
that's not legal unless you have a
specific license that's a lot of
paperwork and very expensive so here's
my point huge I'm huge waiting list I'm
I understand that most people are like
you they don't fully know what it is but
the second you owned a firearm you know
what a semi-automatic is so that's where
I ask you I challenge leftist if when
you hear Hillary Clinton Barack Obama
whoever it is using that as a term to
conflate the issues they obviously know
better but they're deliberately using it
to mislead Americans into thinking what
you thought until we had this
conversation well so that's also why
people come from this from different
schools so the the the world that I live
in what I've been trying to do is talk
about ideas I've been trying to talk
about ideology I've been trying to talk
about means that make people do things
so if we were to get into any of that if
we could get into any of that you're not
gonna get me on any of that but so I
don't focus on I'm not trying to get you
but it's politicians who are misleading
and it's very easy to mislead people in
LA or New York not so much the rest of
the country and that's why it creates
this mindset of civil war and they treat
people like these dumb bumpkins whereas
the the fact is when it comes to
firearms there are people who know
anything and people who know nothing and
my issue is Hillary Clinton Barack Obama
they're surrounded by semi automatics
you have to attribute it to collusion
and so it's the same thing with the
terror list or no flight it doesn't it
doesn't mean anything you can get put on
it do you could be put on the terror
list or no-fly lists if Donald Trump
wins and he doesn't like you for
speaking out against them no just for
come on the show yeah I'm sure he
wouldn't be thrilled with that with my
show either but my bigger point was I
know you're not trying to get me on that
I'm not worried about
her point was that people like us who
are in the public space we come at this
from different philosophical parts so
you come at it more of you want to
protect the Second Amendment and it's
sort of purest form and I'm coming more
at the philosophical side of some of the
ideological stuff but that's why these
conversations have to happen yeah yes
I bet here's the one thing I bet if you
had a firearm if you'd ever purchased a
firearm or if you knew what an ar-15 was
it went and fired it you would never
have the same opinion in the Second
Amendment again I mean philosophically
you wouldn't if you understood what
these firearms are that's why I say
that's the paperwork if you do will you
do the paper I just hate paperwork no no
that's all point I I'm starting a gift
of gun hashtag gift a gun because anyone
who's ever purchased a firearm can call
BS when people are out there spouting
these talking points you will never
believe it again that someone is legally
purchasing a firearm or an automatic
weapon without a background check
once you've ever purchased a firearm
you'll never believe it again that's why
I say it's not to get you it is such a
pivotal moment in someone's view on the
Second Amendment and an ar-15 is a
glorified high-pressure 22 round it's
it's less powerful than hunting rifles
that I have here in this house so like
you've talked about education though
specifically on guns the technicalities
matter because people think of them as
these these scary things and don't know
what they are and they're deliberately
being misled can I get that gun that
Jesse Ventura had in predator do you
have that I would like that firearm as
well that's again was like kind of what
he called minigun I don't remember that
one and the guy I interviewed him once
and he said it was like actually being
held by somebody off camera because it
wasn't even like a real no no it's not
it's not practical yeah but like the
term assault weapon doesn't mean
anything right I've used this as an
example this is I've talked about this
it's not loaded this is illegal I don't
know if it's illegal in California but
that is a basic revolver right well that
has over 10 rounds that's beyond
capacity that's an assault weapon so
people need to understand that that is
an assault weapon you can have a basic
hunting rifle that's an assault weapon
you can have an ar-15 or a gun that this
guy used depending on modification that
isn't and so I really do think
information and what these firearms are
is important because it's one of those
issues right probably like the freedom
of speech issue if you once you speak on
campus you see that it's real
once somebody fires a firearm or
purchases one their opinion changes
forever they're never pro-gun control it
doesn't happen right and actually that's
why the truth of what we're talking
about when you talk about Orlando is
right smack in between of what we're
talking about so you're laying out
you're laying out serious and
understandable cases about guns and and
all that and then what I'm talking about
is the ideology that would allow people
to pick up one of those things and say
I'm gonna murder right innocent people
and it's those two things together so of
course the hysterics on both sides are
always going to say if you if you want
to hide the truth about Islamism you'll
say it's about guns if you want to hide
the truth about guns you'll say it's
right ISM is it you know and all that
but the truth is it's right in the
middle and I know that you for whatever
weapons you have in your house right now
I'm pretty sure that steven crowder is
not going out to shoot innocent people
tonight because as much as people may
say you're a racist bigot I actually
hate isn't in your heart even though you
want people to think that it is oh you
better be careful sir I will if you come
meet me in Texas territory you are in
for a rude awakening when I get with my
boys and we throw back some Bud Lights
and the pickup truck nobody around me
come on we met on the street the other
day that you gave me a hug you you
wouldn't let go
this guy's gay he must have smelled
delicious
he's a lovely guy in the first thing he
said was I knew you were a big guy I
didn't realize you people always say
that I think it could have a relatively
small head compared to most broadcasters
you're very large you're very large I'm
large and in charge and I'd I would
disagree I don't think the truth here is
in the middle I and I think you would
agree the truth here is more toward the
right where it is an Islamic problem and
we need to acknowledge it the ideology
is more important but yeah if we need to
get you either a firearm or get you to
arrange we'll make a video because I
think that is one of the issues it saves
lives good example kids when they were
put in a room alone with the gun what
they never tell you that the twenty kids
they were playing they were put in the
mouths the two kids who were entirely
responsible it was the only two kids who
were trained with guns it changes the
way you put I'm sorry we're going to a
break mr. Rubin we have to let you go
Rubin youtube.com slash Rubin report
done oh here you go Sega Genesis
we got the sonic song yeah just on it
and we have to go I didn't hug Dave
Rubin that never happened that's a lot
of wealth prouder stay tuned
[Music]
I'm hungry
[Music]
glad to be back got caught in the
Riptide there are monsters in these here
parts seem your monsters around these
parts these parts you're not very nice
around these parts here with riptides
dave rubin at dave rubin go give the guy
some dough good for him up to $18,000 a
month and fan-funding man yeah the world
has changed he is is more honest than
Walter Cronkite or Dan Rather or Larry
King I know he likes Larry King and
twice the stud Larry King's full of crap
man I don't like Larry King I'm sure
he's a nice guy
but have you ever seen his interviews
lately I'm not
I would he'll interview jenna Marbles
she's on YouTube because so Jenna you're
a YouTube star yes what's that like
Andrew W K some people say you are not
real what else he goes why the white
well you know I I just this is the way I
dress and I feel uh-huh what kind of
shirt are you wearing and I know Andrew
W K wears Fruit of the Loom because that
was what fascinated Larry King do you
ever wear different pants Larry you're
concerning us aa big week man busy week
I feel like I was so tight we we didn't
get to fit everything in there were a
lot of things I wanted to talk about so
she said and that was the problem for
lots of individuals stop it I'm ashamed
that's you should feel great shame these
are nice people this audience here
depends where they're listening oh I
don't blame everybody gosh Islam though
talk about a religion that is just
cursed yeah Mecca can you imagine that
Mecca how many I mean just stampedes
that have happened the crane that have
crane the moment that the lightening
that is that if I remember right there
was a cool video I'll say cool because
people he died if the lightning was for
the rest of all time with this it was a
crazy video stuff happened back to you
Stephen first off you have the
tramplings then the crane at like that's
your holy site Mecca could you imagine
going to
Jesus's tomb and there's a caterpillar
Tractor no rundown like out where's the
terrible where was weird at the bot what
was the empty tomb found well if you
make a left at the John Deere tractor
it's like you know you could use the zoo
in your favorite parts and the
construction is a huge bummer it's
really distracting it ruins the mood
it's not good for anybody but it is a
ruff-ruff religion and man I will tell
you this I openly say this and I think
there are plenty of Muslims out there of
course who are decent people but listen
they are apostates in the general
history of Islam and I think Islam is
evil I will say this I've said it before
Islam is the great evil of our time by
the way if you want me to actually try
and set up sending a firearm to Dave
Rubin tweet me at s Crowder I wonder how
we can do that I think you can do it you
can order to California to an FFL it's
just really hard process it is hard you
can't carry and it's hard to have it in
your house but I really do think that is
an issue
hashtag gift a gun the more people who
have firearms more people who go through
the paperwork and of course if you gift
it get them some kind of a access to a
course or if you send them to a
respectable FFL dealer they almost
always advise a safety course you did
one
yeah they don't offer them there there's
generally they have contacts people who
offer courses yeah I did well it really
is never stopped training never stop
never stop turning and it's fun to train
with a fight is fun someone today said
name me one thing about firearms that is
good for society here's the thing the
right to firearms isn't necessarily
about society it's about individual
rights and that's one thing people do a
lot they conflate individual god-given
human rights with society the thing
about the Second Amendment people will
tell you about the Constitution this is
important because I wanted to go back to
the the sort of rant earlier that people
seem to react to maybe will archive that
as its own video there's no the
Constitution was written by white
racists and slavery well here's what's
so crazy about that slavery was the law
of the land and it continued and they
put in inalienable rights and that was
what was found to be unconstitutional I
said he can't have rights given to them
by God this would have never come to
fruition with atheists it doesn't mean
there aren't good atheist but this is
reality as far as history they said you
can't have an alien bill rights because
that means the rights are given to them
by God not by government we're not
giving them these rights
we can't have that and then say that
we're going to take away rights from
black people that's the justification
for ending slavery that language and
alienable rights you need to understand
that so it was a law of the land they
found that it wasn't reconcilable with
the constitution now and it wasn't
included it was omitted because it was
the law of the land here's the
difference with the second amendment and
it was fixed the second amendment the
law of the land was citizens didn't get
guns from the old world citizens were
not allowed to be to have the
capabilities to fight off a government
that was the law of land and they
expressly went out of their way to say
we are changing the way we do this took
them a while with slavery still before
most other countries but the Second
Amendment was right away why because
they just fought off a tyrannical
government they knew they couldn't do
without it and George Washington for
people that people just love to throw it
around listen I'm not I'm not the
history buff but I've read quite a bit
i'm a founding fathers George Washington
is one of the very very few people in
history and I mean of the best
presidents of the best world leaders
throughout any Empire or great nation
who walked away and said I don't want
this power and people were saying you
need to be they loved him George
Washington probably could have been
president till the day he died said nope
too much power for one man can't do it
that is incredibly noble and these are
people who said no too much power if you
look at these founding fathers they
pushed away the power that people look
at that's human nature they want to give
certain people power give unto us a king
and they said no and also let's make
sure that all of you have the ability to
fight off a king so it is very different
people will try and tell you well the
Constitution is dated it was written by
racist white men as Samantha bee who
uses salon or slate as sources on
ironically the second Amendment when
taken literally is very very clear when
you give it more context it's even more
clear let's contrast that with what I
believe to be the great evil our time
islam when taken literally kill them
wherever they lie when taken literally
beat your wife when taken literally kill
all Christians and Jews it's really bad
when taken more contextually and you
understand abrogation Muhammad's later
work superseding
earlier work it gets increasingly
violent when taken more contextually the
Quran gets worse so again with the
second amendment in Quran the literal
interpretation seems really clear and
the context only adds to that so get the
context do your research
read the Quran read the Constitution
talk to you next week
[Music]
you